clash event ils se déroule en présentiel
ou en ligne vivez comprenez en direct
les parties des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète avec les commentaires en
français de nos experts notre moteur
d'analyse l'explorateur d'ouverture et
les tables bases retrouvez toutes les
infos essentielles comme le programme
les horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les comptes-rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
bon bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
deuxième jour du tournoi de Blitz du
tata style chess India ravi de vous
retrouver poursuivre évidemment
notre champion du monde 2021 de Blitz
Maxime va chier la grave qui a été
grandiose dans les rapides avec un score
de 7 sur 9 donc ça il a gagné ça c'est
fait
c'est terminé et
ensuite dans le toit de Blitz ça a été
un peu plus compliqué mais
disons petite forme de Maxime combiné à
des expérimentations qui ont pas très
bien marché
4 sur 9 c'est pas extraordinaire mais
bon c'est le minimum syndical disons
pour Maxime il est un peu revenu sur la
fin de journée donc on va on espère une
remontée
évidemment on va regarder ça tout de
suite le
classement avec pragallanda le jeune
joueur indien qui est quand même
extraordinaire si c'est demi sur neuf
visite sur 9 et
4 et demi sur 9 et Maxime qui vient avec
4 accompagnés
pardon l'arrondi va commencer et ce sera
Maxime Vacher la grave avec les Blancs
contre grisou qu'on a versé couleur très
très curieux de voir cette première
partie il va falloir commencer pied au
plancher
avec Christina Vidy à 12 ans et
le leader face à rajabov effectivement
j'ai vu bonjour à tous j'ai vu que le
titre du stream était pas bon et je
crois que je peux pas le changer
malheureusement faut que j'attende
quelqu'un qui s'occupe de ça notre ami
Nathan
on va voir on va voir tout ça mais on
est bien au tata style
chess India on va faire comme ça ou là
non non pas du tout on va ramasser une
partie la partie de Maxime et on a
Maxime en plein écran
on est content on va faire ça
pour essayer quand même
voilà
et donc on a Maxime on va essayer une
nouvelle vie aujourd'hui je vais pas
dans le public je mets comme ça on va
voir
Nathan Nathan ce qui donne faut qu'il
fasse des heures supplément
qui s'occupe du stream et de normalement
c'est assez impec clairement donc
[Musique]
c'est assez impec mais là c'est un oubli
je suppose
pour pour ce matin
alors j'ai pas regardé le match hier
mais je vais regarder après
j'ai trop de regarder de de rugby quand
j'étais jeune mais ça a l'air sympa les
horaires sympa l'équipe
ils ont l'air sympa à l'équipe de rugby
là qui a gagné qui a battu la
Nouvelle-Zélande je regardais à l'époque
dans ma jeunesse
je viens d'une terre de rugby et donc
j'ai regardé énormément de rugby quand
j'étais jeune et depuis je regarde plus
trop je dois avouer
et oui et oui il y a trahison
je sais que le titre est une image
d'hier tout à fait où aller résa elle a
emporté au final
mais je vais regarder les prochains là
ils ont su créer un engouement je trouve
donc oui le titre va être changé
j'espère
j'attends Nathan
quid de cramique Niman
qu'est-ce que vous voulez
on va voir si gagne comme ça on reste
comme ça sinon on changera très très
important de cette première partie on va
voir s'il va jouer des 4 ou 4 hier
il a joué beaucoup de D4 et s'est
retrouvé dans des positions où il est
pas habitué c'est un jeu de réflexe en
blitz surtout que son style c'est quand
même de jouer vite et donc c'était un
peu dommage je trouve à mon sens
mais bon on va voir
on va voir
il faut qu'il soit surtout dans une
meilleure forme c'était vraiment la
forme la forme basse clairement donc on
va voir moi je préférais voir le 4 mais
j'y crois pas je crois qu'on va voir on
va on va voir on va voir des quatre
premiers coups donc le pion de la dame
qui est pas du tout son coup de
d'enfants c'est important de jouer de
jouer ses coups d'enfants pour
retomber dans des schémas très connus
son coup de jeunesse c'est le coup qu'il
a propulsé dans le top mondial jusqu'au
titre de champion du monde de Blitz et
C4 jouer par mvl
cavalier F6 ok ok c'est 3 et gretchou
qui normalement va prendre beaucoup de
temps dans le début même si c'est après
ça reste un excellent blitzer KF3 qui
est ici j'ai trois fou B4 ça c'est une
des lignes principales il y avait des 7
dessins aussi qui existait
mais c'est normal qu'il y ait des cinq
et ici la tentative de réfutation mais
non et je fou j'ai deux
ouais bravo Ali esa hier parce que
c'était c'était très très chaud
effectivement là on Roque on va essayer
de jouer D4 assez rapidement de clouer
comme ça avec fougères 5 tout ça est
très très connu des 6 peut-être une
petite sous variance mais je suis même
pas sûr petit vraiment le coup ici hein
petit rock 4 cavalier H4 c'est archi
compliqué
à Maxime qui connaît pas du tout
une fois de plus 30 secondes déjà il
prend en B4 c'est pas du tout le coup
normalement en tout cas dans cette
position
bon mais ça reste une position
complètement jouable on l'a vu beaucoup
souffert surtout avec les Noirs il y a
donc on va voir
le 30 secondes d'avance 40 maintenant
rendez-vous compte c'est extrêmement
rare
H6 on empêche se fout dehors qui est un
peu dominé par la chaîne des pions noirs
donc finalement l'avantage de la paire
de fou je joue pas tellement
ça un petit sacrifice de pion ça ça va
faire réfléchir gricho pas du tout il
encaisse il encaisse tout il a trois
minutes à la pendule ça veut dire qu'il
connaît contre de 10
ça commence mal
enfin bon c'est pas évidemment pas
terminé
on va jouer une sorte de Gambie banco
ici qui a été deux on va mettre les
tours par là peut-être la dame par là la
dame à 4 et la tour en V1 c'est qu'il y
a du jeu il y a quand même ce pion là
qui est faible mais ça reste un pion
et une nuit de moins surtout pour mvl
qui est pas dansé schéma là
on va voir s'il va retomber s'il va
réussir à retomber sur ses pattes
normalement il arrive à retomber sur ses
pattes il joue très lentement là
allez Maxime plus vite damaka je vous
l'avais dit il veut faire tomber un et
faire pression avec ces deux tours sur
les colonnes
semi-ouvertes sur les deux pions en B7
et à 7 mais pour l'instant ils sont très
bien protégés on va certainement voir
tourbillon attention il y a eu 4
attention E4 menaces et il est moins
bien d'après la jauge beaucoup moins
bien maintenant 4 je suis posé le coup
on va voir si gris Tchouk réfléchit
il fait ça pour prendre l'expérience
ouais d'accord mais bon quand même c'est
un peu dommage
je crois qu'il fait une expérimentation
voir s'il peut pas jouer d'autres
ouvertures puis il y a le il y a le il y
a le grand Suisse qui arrive bientôt
donc peut-être ne rien montrer
et forcer les autres joueurs à se
préparer sur d'autres schémas MC2 on se
prend parfois cinq tout de suite parce
qu'il y aurait le pion B7 quoi que il y
aurait cavalier c'est 5 bref c'est
compliqué
mais faut F5 tout de suite semble un peu
un peu trop rapide d'abord on va
protéger spion comment on fait peut-être
un coup de dame 7 un coup de dame C7 et
ensuite on va venir avec le fou F5
première réflexion de Sacha ça fait du
bien et oui désolé pour le titre je ne
ce n'est pas mon pouvoir de le changer
donc j'attends j'attends les nouvelles
désolé
désolé Ah j'ai pas le score ici voilà je
vais rajouter vraiment
je manque à tout mais de voir on a le
score on va rajouter le score évidemment
c'est où
c'est ça c'est pardon
pardon
autant pour moi le score ça évitera de
demander quel tournoi c'est il a déjà
gagné le rapide dans le rappel
et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé d'un C2 il
y a eu fou F5 et oui je vous en parlais
d'un petit imbé 6 tomber 5 fois 7 et les
Noirs un pion de plus tout simplement et
il y a une faiblesse ici pour les blancs
en C4 ça va pas du tout
et lancer le stream youtube il est pas
lancé le stream YouTube si il est ah il
est lancé sur chaise 24 pas surchauffe
[Musique]
on va voir
ah désolé ouais désolé désolé
c'est pour ça que j'aime bien avoir le
contrôle de tout franchement quand je
vais lancer stream comme ça parce que
parfois il y a des petits il y a des
petits oublis on le fait à plusieurs
allez Maxime allez il a récupéré un pion
et d'un F4 comme d'habitude il est quand
même alors il a
a beau ne pas bien connaître les débuts
qui jouent dans ce tournoi il est quand
même alerte tactiquement ça ça ne change
pas c'est une donnée invariable de
Maxime va chez Lagrave
mais par exemple après dame 7 tours
prendre à me prendre deux on voit pas
trop les compenses en tout cas je les
vois pas mais on va voir grichu qui se
met mal au temps une 15 vous me direz là
il va encaisser le pion bien sûr qu'il
va encaisser le pion Sacha
et encaisse pas du tout le pion il y a
peut-être une peau de banane où il a eu
peur
je sais pas et cavalier prend des 8 qui
va certainement arriver
et ça va on a récupéré notre pion avec
les Blancs effectivement la structure
est plutôt pas mal pour les Noirs mais
ça reste complètement jouable ce qui
m'inquiète plus c'est toujours ce retard
autant contre quelque chose qui
normalement
censé
censé être plus lent ah il vient de voir
Nathan on a des nouvelles de Nathan
c'est parfait
il y a eu un petit problème
on va changer ça
on va changer ça il est en train de
corriger là vous allez voir
et je vais dire
je vais lui dire aussi qu'il faut lancer
le stream
YouTube cheesecom
et donc on attaque ce fou
et attention bon il y a rien du tout
pour Maxime ça va pas du tout
mais ouais le cavalier va être là on a
une position très très solide la tour en
17 puis on a passé potentiellement qui
fait gagner les finales de pions les
finales de cavalier donc ça c'est pas
bon c'est pas bon pour le long terme
ça ne va pas
ça ne va pas pour Maxime mais bon est-ce
que il va faire des miracles
il est changé d'arme Richou évidemment
il a plus de risques et B5 attention
on peut prendre ces quatre à ce
moment-là on se vengerait sur le pion a
et ça irait pour les blancs j'ai
l'impression qu'il est en train de s'en
sortir Maxime ma chérie quand même mais
bon on aurait besoin de toi à cette
heure là
on essaie de marquer des points les les
nuls sont pas les bienvenus A5 jouer
tour B1 il va se venger sur ça et il va
se placer derrière non évidemment qu'on
échange pas on garde les tours ah quoi
qu'il est tombé deux
ça c'est un problème
c'est un problème pour Maxime il
réfléchit et 18 secondes tout raciste
tourbé 2 et on prend F2 on est moins
bien mais on devrait s'en sortir
bien son rôle et ça va faire nul il va
la tenir mvl cavalier un peu moins bien
mais ça reste ouais maintenant ça reste
plus anecdotique ou symbolique comme
vous voulez
qu'autre chose quoi que dès qu'on bouge
la tour il y a cavalier E4 j'arrive pas
à changer d'avis et nul proposé par
glitchouk ok ok ok ok on va voir ce qui
nous reste
ce qu'on a à se mettre sous la dent et
il nous reste à Krishna contre
visite visite qui nous a fait des
parties hier et ouais il a il a il a
gagné à Krishna
et on voit les deux joueurs qui
s'apprécient clairement et qui discute
après la partie voilà tout a été corrigé
merci beaucoup à notre ami
Nathan merci beaucoup vous voyez c'est
corriger tout de suite
ça c'est ça c'est très actif
alors
on va regarder les résultats et une
nulle qui nous arrange pas contre gris
chouk avec Christian a battu Vidy
beaucoup de victoire blanche à d'où ça
te va
battu avec Easy et paranga a battu
rajabov confortant sa première place au
niveau du classement on voit
triple champion du monde de Blitz
feat 6 points
Abdou cette avec 5 points
et
ensuite on a Éric et
MVR la 4 et demi
à 50 %, après 10 rondes il reste plus
que 8 3 points de retard la femelle de
turbo absolument si on veut jouer les
les premières places après on peut
essayer de jouer un podium aussi on voit
vite il est à 6 points simplement donc
un point et demi de retard ça va vite il
suffit de le battre
un jabov deux points enfin il suffit de
le battre c'est toujours pareil on va
regarder évidemment maintenant les
appareils mangent de la ronde 11 contre
qui joue
Maxime je crois qu'il va jouer Prague le
leader ah ça serait
ça serait important de mettre un point
voilà c'est une partie capitale contre
Prague il a les noirs
et
il doit l'emporter s'il veut garder une
micro chance de gagner ce tournoi
Raja Bove gamer et easy abdossator of
gooche avec Krishna et visite contre
gretchup bon bah ça c'est le deuxième
compte de 3e belle partie aussi on va
regarder
ici on va tout de suite se mettre sur la
partie de Maxime on va changer son score
aussi vous voyez tout un programme à
chaque fois
pour Maxime on va évidemment changer
alors je me fasse un gronder par la
foule mécontente on va changer
le
on va se mettre du côté mvl et on va
changer son score qui est de 4 et demi
sur 10
score tout à fait modeste pour pour
Maxime évidemment par rapport évidemment
ça tourne très fort donc il y a aucune
honte à être dans la zone de des 50%
mais par rapport à ces standards
c'est quand même
allez on change premier rang pour
l'annexe je crois je crois qu'on va
faire ça allez
allez chez qui est hop là regardez-moi
ça
premièrement
on sait pas pour l'instant on est là on
sait pas quel échec qui va être Maxime
va chez La Grave
on essaie comme ça on sait plus quoi
faire
on sait plus quoi faire
pour porter chance porter bonheur à
Maxime
je rappelle que le speechester
Championship a lieu ces trois prochaines
semaines lundi lundi il y aura m VL qui
jouera face à Google
favori et hier Andri King gros match
j'ai vu un petit peu la fin un petit peu
le début un petit peu la fin je sais pas
si vous avez si vous avez suivi
mais c'était un gros match André King
ouais André King il a tendance à être
sous-estimé mais gros joueur gros joueur
André King qui s'entraîne beaucoup sur
Internet qui joue tous ces tournois à
Internet et donc qui est très chaud déjà
et très chaud en live évidemment très
très grand joueur ancien champion de
Russie
et en sia finaliste de la Coupe du monde
en 2013 donc pour aller jusqu'en final
en Coupe du Monde c'est quand même assez
incroyable
donc il a donné beaucoup de fil à
retordre à notre ami à lire ETA qui
finalement l'emportait
mais c'était chaud
alors est-ce qu'il y a un classement
combiné rapide et Blitz non ce sont deux
temps assez parés Pablo CDF voilà donc
ça c'est c'est fait pour le rapide et
pour le Blitz il va falloir
il va falloir ça serait bien au moins un
podium quand même
Maxime il nous a habitué à ça
ah au moins au moins au moins des
podiums en
[Musique]
Blitz dans un Torah comme ça mais bon
c'est jeune joueur qui sont bons mais on
sent que Maxime est en dessous des
habitudes c'est ça le problème
il gagne il gagne beaucoup de tournoi
sur sur Internet notamment les tailles
Tuesday je crois que c'est un des trois
quatre joueurs qui a fait
qui a gagné les deux titles
dans la journée c'est-à-dire celui le
early à 17h et le Late à 23 heures
il a fini combien rapide il a fini
premier il a été étincelant faut
s'abonner à nos réseaux sociaux pour
suivre la chaikos si tu étais abonné à
chaise comme fr sur Twitter enfin x
Facebook Instagram ou autre ou sur les
chaînes tu le saurais
il a été fabuleux tu as raté un grand
truc
ouais il a remporté au moins le premier
tournoi oui tout à fait
et il essaie de revenir dans le deuxième
on va voir c'est mal parti nul avec Chou
bon pas grave mais là il y a une grosse
partie contre Prague qui va il va pas me
lire Prague a priori il va quand même
essayer de
d'enfoncer le clou parce que finalement
les joueurs sont pas tellement derrière
lui il a les blancs il y a pas de raison
d'essayer de gagner de pas essayer de
gagner il y a pas de raison assez de
gagner il y a pas de raison de pas
essayer de gagner par contre si Maxime
le bas il revient simplement à deux
points comme on le voit sur ce
classement il a 4 ennemis Prague à cette
ennemi en fait finalement c'est assez
serré comme on le voit ici
mais bon on va voir on va voir une belle
partie de toute façon prochaine partie
c'est tout des 20 minutes les parties
donc là ça semble un peu long
mais parce que les parties il y a pas eu
de partie où
il y a un joueur normalement il y a
toujours un joueur normalement c'est
vite qui sentait un petit peu qui a
envie de gagner quoi qu'il arrive
et donc il prend énormément de risques
et qu'il ajoute à fond à fond les
ballons jusqu'au bout
on voit les arbitres qui s'attelle non
je les vois sur mon écran ici les
arbitres qui s'attelent pour mettre les
petits drapeaux et les petits noms
est-ce qu'on retrouve nos drapeaux
français
je le vois pas en tout cas pour
l'instant on va voir ce qui se passe
c'est du boulot les arbitres bossent là
pour le coup pour le temps
alors n'hésitez pas à vos questions
c'est très bien on va francer ça on fait
des questions réponses quand on a le
temps autre question à jour à lire Elsa
est qualifié pour les candidats non
combien de place il reste il reste deux
places au grand Suisse à l'île de Man
qui va se jouer fin octobre où on aura
pas mal de français on aura un beau
contagion français avec cinq Français à
lire et zafiroja Maxime Vacher La Grave
évidemment qui joueront pour ces deux
places Étienne maquereau Jules Moussa
et
Marc Andréa morizy pardon
donc 5 français pour deux places enfin
il y aura pas que des Français il y aura
il y aura énormément de monde et ensuite
à Lisa il a une petite chanson ce jour
entre lui et Nakamura et la 277
Nakamura 2780 et ça sera celui qui a le
meilleur et long en janvier au 1er
janvier
alors allez savoir
allez savoir qui sera le
et à noter que les qualifiés pour
l'instant donc c'est le perdant du mal
champion du monde Yann les pomyachi
les trois joueurs de la Coupe du monde
donc ça fait
car wanna
Prague et Magnus Carson mais a priori
Magnus Carcen va laisser sa place et
donc ça sera à base of à sa place le
terrible Amazon donc ça c'est quatre
joueurs ensuite
ensuite il y a deux joueurs du Grand
Suisse il y a une autre place il y a une
place où est l'eau
et la dernière place c'est le fil des
circuits c'est-à-dire celui qui
comptabilise qui fait la meilleure
saison avec les points fidèles et pour
l'instant c'est Google qui en tête de
Van Giri je crois
et moi je ne veux pas tenter ma chance
au grand Suisse et non Pablo CDF parce
que le grand Suisse il est à l'île de
Man en octobre et que je ne vais
j'aime pas la pluie ni le vent ni le
froid donc j'y vais pas c'est trop fort
j'y crois plus
je vais faire 11 nuls quand je joue à
toi comme ça non mais quand je vois
comme ça je vais faire au moins 9 nuls
un gars une victoire un gars une défaite
de victoire de défaite pas claire mais
j'y crois plus
allez on a Prague
face à
face à évidemment
bien le meilleur d'entre nous
mvl allez on essaie une petite
[Musique]
une petite vue comme ça voilà dans le
public allez première
rang première rang oh là on est bien là
oh là on est on est premier ah oui
on a double ah non
on n'y arrive pas c'est sur un vide le
grand Suisse ouais c'est les 100
meilleurs joueurs du monde plus ça ça
décale parce qu'il y a toujours plein
qui refusent donc ça va jusqu'à 150 à
peu près
et ensuite pour les jeunes voilà c'est
comme ça que mardi il a eu
carlsaint tant que la formule est comme
ça non il compte pas rejouer
après
si la formule change mais le temps passe
aussi vous savez et oui
donc je pense pas qu'il rejouera
honnêtement parce que le temps passe
il avait annoncé un petit peu ouh là
13,57 là il y a un bug ah non 3-02 et on
voit que F3 G3 ça c'est bien pour Maxime
on ne sait pas de l'attraper dans
l'ouverture on ne sait pas lui faire du
mal ça c'est bon pour nous ça parce que
avec les Noirs il est qu'est-ce qu'il a
souffert c'était affreux
alors on joue un système symétrique
Maxime avec les Noirs
est-ce qu'il va faire C4 oui à faire ces
trois dans ces 4 C6 on a le rock solide
et damac 4
calife tout ça est très connu
je jouais ça à l'époque avec les Blancs
dans ma 4 en force un peu en protège ce
pion et en force les blancs les noirs a
fait un coup bizarre qu'il y a fd7 et on
découpe principaux ici
qui menaçait on n'a pas envie de prendre
des 5 de relâcher l'attention pour
garder essayer d'avoir un avantage à 5
on prend à 4 et puis on prend tout ça
hiérarchie thématique là je crois qu'on
joue dans ma 5
donc et B6 ok
il faut F4 Prague connais son histoire
et comme d'habitude Maxime à 30 secondes
de moins dans ses Blitz dès le début
c'est pas bon il a joué cavalier C6 on
n'a pas le date qu'est-ce qui se passe
on n'a pas le update on n'a pas les
coûts ici alors j'essaie de les deviner
ah si c'est bon et c'est 6 tours c'est
un fouet 5 B3 ça arrive quand les
joueurs à double mal
non ça tombe dans une greenfeld avec G3
donc est indienne cela je connaisfeld
avec G3
la Catalane il faut qu'il y a un pion
aussi
et dames des 7 pour faire fout H3 Dame
des deux aussi et tout tout l'avantage
des blancs s'il y en a un résident le
fait que ce qu'elle est en V6 il est pas
très bien placé parce que vous voyez ce
pur en B3 le domine bien c'est ça l'idée
après normalement c'est pas assez pour
avoir un vrai un avantage conséquent ça
c'est clair
salut Gégé 303 je crois que le BTP ne
travaille pas aujourd'hui
on a du bol
pas de bruit fenêtre ouverte
il fait pas trop chaud il y a pas de
bruit
fait plaisir
samedi en même temps il manquait plus
que ça
alors Maxime il veut prendre un F3 et
prendre des cartes qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ici c'est pas si clair si on prend le
cavalier on va reprendre il y aura spion
faible en décape donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de chatouiller ce pur en V4
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire est-ce qu'il va
jouer trois ou quelque chose comme ça
je pense pas ça paire d'être mon coup
peut-être cavalier 5
mais faut calculer à ce moment-là que 5
et prank et prend le 4 j'en sais rien ce
qui se passe ici ça a pas l'air ça a
l'air de provoquer des échanges massifs
et pra qui prend son temps ça c'est bon
pour nous
voilà l'idée le plan baignoire poussé au
centre un jeu de pièces sur eldom non
l'idée c'est de jouer solide pour
l'instant et on voit en fonction il
prend le 4 il va jouer cavalier 5 voilà
il veut jouer la petite finale où on a
la paire de fou certes mais normalement
c'est pas assez voyez il s'active il
prend il joue tout à deux
et normalement ça sort avec les Noirs
mais pas plus
pas plus que s'en sortir
et malheureusement ça fait pas nos
affaires
et tourner attention à ce pion en B7
quand on perd le 4 le problème c'est que
le pion V7 derrière devient très très
faible
ah c'est quand même c'est quand même
ballot
il va prendre lequel je suppose Prague
attaquer B7 alors tour des 8 mais
attention il faut acheter
toujours un peu désagréable ça pour les
Noirs peut-être tomber deux
pour essayer de se venger sur B3
mais clairement c'est Maxime qui fait et
qui doit faire attention ici tomber deux
jouez et surtout Béar je suppose qu'on
va prendre et jouer tour des 8 que ah
non remarqué il y a x 5 à la fin je sais
pas comment on va faire
tomber peut-être tourner 8
x 5
que c'est désagréable avec cette paire
de fou ton bien joué
une 09 contre une 49 c'est ça le motif
de satisfaction c'est le temps x 5 la
maquette un peu je m'en doute
cette fois-ci ceci mais quoique fois 600
prendre un bien
ok c'est ça son idée
mais alors que c'est dur fou des trois
ouais clou le débat sur la colonne des
mais là ce pion en vie ouais un cavalier
donc le fameux mais ça paraît tellement
solide pour les blancs
tellement solide pour les blancs
malheureusement
on voit pas on voit pas comment Maxime
pourrait l'emporter je pense qu'il va
falloir viser un top 3
top 3 toujours envisageable oui
oui parce que si on gagne deux trois
parties et c'est possible dans cet oral
Blitz et bien on remonte on remonte
rapidement qu'il y a des 5 faut faire
qui c'est 3 pour échanger fou un logique
les fous loin comme ça on se fait pas
attaquer
mais attention si Prague un peu trop
ambitieux ça peut tourner aussi
alors est-ce qu'on fait qui c'est 3 ou
pas et c'est 3 a l'air pas mal
ok c'est 3 pose des questions
non il va jouer il va jouer il joue
qu'il C3 mvl si on veut garder les faux
on est obligé de faire tomber deux
mais attention un peu risqué cette
histoire si tour c'est un tour reprend
des trois bon ça il va le voir et
cavalier de échecs
donc c'est soit vous prends ces trois et
nulle tout de suite soit tombé deux et
on a de la chance ça marche pas cette
combinette parce que tu reprends tout
reprend et elle fout à la fin en prise
et tomber de jouer par Prague
et tomber deux il a joué fouf 6 m VL
tour C2 maintenant il menacé deux
maintenant on peut prendre du fou parce
que la tourne est plus en prise et on
est un peu moins bien on souffre l'école
française de la souffrance de retour
pour C8 3g2 maintenant
quelque chose comme ça
bon mais ça reste quand même raisonnable
ranger de jouer peut-être pour C7 pour
essayer de garder un contact sur cette
tour mais assez cahier des 5 mais bon
les blancs sont bien les blancs sont
mieux ça ça fait aucun doute paire de
fou
zéro risque et tant que tant qu'inspire
en B7 ça reste une faiblesse potentielle
alors pour ces 6 il veut protéger mais
en F3 va arriver
et non il fait 4
ambitieux menace de gagner une pièce
avec E5 alors comment on fait maintenant
est-ce qu'on fait fout des quatre où
est-ce qu'on bouge le cavalier mais où
est-ce qu'on bouge le cavalier je sais
pas non bouge pas le cavalier bref 3
peut-être 5 un peu acrobatique mais ça a
l'air de marcher attention à des coûts
comme 5 on prend l'espace le roi ah il
fait F5 dit stop altos sketch plus plus
de temps pour Prague ça c'est bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur tous ces
quatre cavaliers 4 tout simplement et si
il a plus de temps faut qu'il fasse
attention contre Maxime on sait jamais
il peut y avoir une embellie là
ça serait sympa avec 5 il y a toujours
qu'à les prendre attention ça sera une
gaffe oh mais cette non vraiment
vraiment ça marchait
oh là là
ça marche et ça gagne un peu ça a gagné
probablement pas la partie mais voilà
nul nul foot clore opposé H3 H5 et foot
couleur opposé oh quel dommage ça aurait
été une belle escroquerie là il y a Eric
gazy contrat d'où ça torov ou alors
je pense que c'est de la cam
numéro
ouais celle-là
et on va tourner les chéquiers
en plat et
blanc qui joue pourquoi ouh là
les noirs sont mieux avec Dame cavalier
mais attention le roi un peu
pas hyper safe on a ce matin et
proposition de nulle quasi à moins que
abdos à Toro filaire et envie de jouer
en général
il a envie de la jouer les deux jours en
ville à jouer mais bon et nul il se
regarde
et nul signé
plus de partie on va aller voir tout de
suite les résultats de la ronde Raja bof
avec
nul contre mvl
dommage il a pas eu vraiment de
de chance de gagner cette partie
toute couleur opposé avec un pion de
plus oui c'est nul quand même et il y a
pas de pion de plus effectivement
à la fin
et donc on a
airigazie qu'on a vu il a fini la
cabosaurore vous cache abattu avec
Krishna et gretchup dans le duel pour le
podium ah bah tu lui dit
c'est pas mal pour notre troisième place
on voit les deux joueurs Prague et 7 et
demi qui vont certainement se disputer
la victoire finale on y croit plus mais
vite à 6 points Google
on joue on a un point des
un point des du troisième et voilà là ça
peut aller très très vite il reste
encore cette partie donc clairement
objectif podium là pour mvl je crois que
c'est plus réaliste de penser à la
première place
on va regarder tout de suite et il a
joué quand même deux des meilleurs
blitzer de ce tournoi dans les deux
premiers Prague et
on va regarder tout ça
Maxime va chier la grave on va aller
blanc contre vide très important une
fois de plus les blancs conduites
pourquoi parce que vous dites et l'homme
seul troisième s'il le bat
on l'attrape et on rattrape surtout
gretchu
et on a les blancs contre vidite il peut
aller chercher vite ouais alors là
attention vous dites il est très bien
préparé ça va être aussi important à
l'ouverture arrive à s'entêter dans son
C4 là en général c'est comme ça la
première partie est quand même une bonne
indication on va pas s'entêter vous
voyez on va pas si vous préparer quelque
chose vous jouez ces cas toute la
journée normalement et si ça marchera
pas vous passez à quelque chose d'autre
mais là c'est trop tôt donc il va pas
changer on prépare pas 50 ouverture on
prépare on prépare pas une ouverture par
par joueur
c'est vrai j'ai gg07 s'il fait top 1 en
rapide et top 3 ce sera un très bon
résultat clairement il y a pas de il y a
pas de souci là-dessus
ouais après moi je trouve que 3 + 2
honnêtement
Stéphane qui nous dit c'est clair que
c'est quand même plus sympa regarder les
rapides et Blitz je suis d'accord
ouais c'est ce qui plaît accélérer les
cadences permettrait de fédérer un
nouveau public tout à fait je suis 100%
d'accord et je crois qu'il faut garder
les parties longues pour les amateurs
pour qui joue
parce que souvent ça va trop vite
les gens ont envie de faire leur partie
de réfléchir ça il y a pas de problème
mais je crois que pour le niveau
il faut des rapides et Blitz là c'est un
peu rapide trois plus de je préfère le 5
+ 3 du Grand chesto nettement on a plus
le temps de commenter L3 plus 2 est
vraiment très très rapide parfois on a
des séries de coups les joueurs du mal
c'est un peu trop rapide à mon goût
voilà 5 + 3 ça me semble idéal
salut Paul la cagole
prochaine partie dans cette petite
minute
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
la discuter dans la bonne humeur
à bienveillance
voilà
en attendant je vous fais un petit
rappel un petit pouce
un petit pouce bleu un abo à la chaîne
et comme ça vous ne ratez plus rien et
les réseaux sociaux comme ça vous êtes
informés sympa quand même
les parties sont rapides pour les
amateurs Jean 25 minutes pour les
intercopes ça serait génial bah ça je
trouve ça plus discutable honnêtement
parce que je sais je sais d'expérience
avec les amateurs aiment bien
faire leur partir réfléchir c'est quand
même un jeu compliqué
parce que 25 minutes donc tu en fais
plusieurs dans la journée pourquoi pas
aussi c'est ce que proposer manuscarsen
c'est de faire au lieu de faire une
partie long quatre parties de 25 + 10
par jour
et effectivement ça permet aussi de
jouer plus de parties de définir d'une
façon plus certaine qu'il est le
meilleur joueur
plutôt que sur un échantillon réduit de
12 ou 14 parties
Maxime va chez Lagrave qui passe à 5 sur
et donc c'est bien et il en faut pour
tous les goûts
je t'ai vu à l'Open de 2 secondes
et oui j'étais à l'Open Hossegor pour
ce tournoi Landé
historique il y a un bouquin qui sort
bientôt sur le tournoi et sur les Landes
en général n'hésitez pas
et donc
ouais on peut danse gore très sympa au
mois de ces fin mai
c'est fin mai
toi il fait beau on est bien
je joue pas moi j'ai fait une simultanée
cette année très très sympa
je vous conseille inscrivez-vous vite
parce que c'est la c'est une salle au
Sporting Sporting casino donc
ça le très très cosy très très belle et
donc ça joue à guichet fermé il refuse
du monde
c'est autre chose que l'île de Manou
ouais la plage est plus sympa quoi
il a quand même point Maxime c'est
marqué
c'est marqué
c'est marqué dessus à combien de points
il a 5 sur 11 malheureusement c'est dur
c'est dur pour l'instant
ouh là
Patrick Delormeau alors là à la Mora
joueur de Dax au départ joueur de
président du club d'échec de Dax les
joueurs de Nîmes maintenant qui m'a
appris la marche des pièces
tu me rappelles des souvenirs ça date
pas d'hier c'est le monsieur je suis
allé au club des chèques
et c'est un formidable bénévole
qui s'appelle Alain Mora qui a pris le
temps
d'apprendre un petit garçon
moi-même donc je suis certainement pas
le seul la marche des pièces aussi
simple que ça
ouais une crème
ah oui on peut pas dire du mal à la mort
pas ici en tout cas
effectivement il y a pas de maladie donc
ça tombe bien
donc voilà
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à ce je sais
pas qui joue qui joue sur Internet qui
joue dans un club mais en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à pousser la porte des
clubs aussi tout en continuant à jouer
sur internet mais ça peut être ça peut
être très sympa aussi d'aller dans des
clubs on peut rencontrer des personnes
on peut faire des belles rencontres
c'est aussi un truc social
ah merci Fab qui nous dit Laurent tu
nous a régalé aux commentaires cette
semaine et la technique tu as vu hein
quand même on fait des progrès
et il a regardé toutes les lives en
replay ouh là
Bernard
les vieux souvenirs et oui bonjour à toi
Bernard ex vainqueur
et oui je me rappelle de Bernard de Pau
salut amical à Bernard
ouais beaucoup plus sympa sur bangloose
qui nous dit beaucoup plus sympa en club
qu'ensible derrière son PC on peut faire
les deux il y a pas de moi je crache pas
dans la soupe non plus c'est sympa aussi
mais les deux
les deux sont bien on va suivre
évidemment MV avec les Blancs allez un
petit coup de 4 non on n'y croit pas il
va faire ses quatre mvl
mais c'est important de gagner pour
rattraper visite et
et espérer
espérer cette troisième place
ou alors en slip on peut aller en slip
au club ouais effectivement bienvenue
le chat ainsi pour club
pourquoi pas avec cette chaleur
allez pour Maxime
c'est important cette partie est très
très importante
parce que non seulement on marque des
points donc les points normaux nuls en
cas de nul un demi point en cas de nul
et un point en cas de victoire mais
on stoppe
on stoppe celui ceux qui sont devant
enfin celui qui est devant visite
ou là je conseille quoi comme tournant
européen
alors ça ça fera l'objet d'une question
à la prochaine pause faut que je
réfléchisse Hossegor déjà pour commencer
ça c'est sûr je conseille ouais moi j'ai
pas des critères tu vois mes critères
c'est qu'il fasse beau donc
qu'appelle la grande par exemple après
vos tournois
c'est sûr
bon c'est en février à côté de Dunkerque
donc
les choix dans la vie
qu'est-ce que c'est les boutons qui
arrivent bientôt
Cap d'Agde de tournoi vraiment avec 800
à 1000 joueurs à chaque fois
Stéphane cosgat qui demande un
torréfaction faisant ses déplacements
non non
sauf pour le Championnat d'Europe
individuel et évidemment pour les
compétitions et l'équipe de France mais
voilà Cannes
en même temps que je vais citer les deux
grands tournois cette période là
perso je préfère le climat de Cannes
c'est comme ça
donc j'irai plutôt à Cannes si je devais
jouer un
alors on a une Réty vous voyez pas ces
quatre mais bon c'est dans le même ordre
d'idées qui évite toute théorie petit
rock
et enfin non ça évite pas toute théorie
mais il y a un peu moins c'est 4 c'est 6
et cavalier 5 un petit coup joué par mvl
intéressant
je crois que le coup c'est que j'ai
quatre là
selon la théorie en tout cas mais vide
qui réfléchit
cavalier E4 aussi un coup et non il
prend ses quatre ok mais ça c'est censé
être un peu inférieur de la on donne le
centre
mais je joue très concrètement il
attaque le cavalier tout de suite et il
veut mettre son four en dessin très
certainement ok BD7 d'abord on va voir
ce qu'il va faire
canne aussi jouer à guichet fermé oui
dans ce magnifique palais des festivals
très très beau
regarde les pièces on avantage d'espace
mais attention à ne pas trop négliger le
développement
cahier des trois menaces cavalie F4
quand même mais attention il fait
toujours un peu peur ces choses là de
pas sentir ses pièces
et vite clairement qui réfléchit pour
essayer de punir tout ça
des cinq et c'est trop en accepte les
changes oh j'aime pas trop ça mais en
même temps F3 était quand même très
moche ici sur les faire F3
ok les Noirs échangent des pièces c'est
logique ils ont moins d'espace peut-être
un petit coup de cahier des cinq pour
poser la question à ce pion des quatre
est-ce qu'elle est en D3 MB6 ok on
attaque le pion la même idée
d'un A4 attaque non protège le pion
pardon en D4 on va certainement mettre
les tours maintenant ou jouer un C5
rapide
il faut voir il est en train de regarder
mais c'est bien pour nous ça 50 secondes
d'avance pour Maxime va chez Lagrave
alors peut-être
une position un petit peu plus
confortable même si on prend ces cinq si
on la joue molle car elle est prank
allez prendre elle me prend feu 3 on va
les tours par là on est quand même un
peu mieux développé et un peu mieux tout
court
il faut 3 directement ok il veut garder
les pièces Maxime c'est bien qu'on prend
en cible est-ce qu'il est G4 qu'est-ce
qui se passe je n'en sais rien peut-être
qu'il est 5 à calculer complexe que G4
il y avait le cavalier en prise je ne
vois rien ce matin puis on prend
et qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec cette
dame est-ce qu'on peut jouer à petite
finale mais en fait moins bien si on
joue à la petite fille mais il y a pas
trop de casque confortable
pour les noirs
pour mvl il va certainement mettre une
tour au centre un truc comme ça
quelque chose comme ça
je suppose
il est en train de calculer évidemment
plus précisément c'est un joueur concret
Maxime Achères à bijoux tour Fd1 comme
annoncé ici le premier cookie vient
c'est le plus naturel on met les tours
sur les colonnes ouvertes n'hésitez pas
à jouer ce genre de coups assez
rapidement en blitz surtout en blitz
parce que c'est rarement mauvais une
tour sur une corne ouverte et un petit
échec et là il peut faire cailler des
cinq certainement échanger quand même
pas mal de pièces et c'est jouer
cavalier prend va arriver
et on va être obligé de faire de jouer
la petite finale mais on n'a pas grand
chose dans la petite finale
et en plus on est même pas obligé de
l'accepter on peut faire prendre et
coller une tour en D8 quelque chose
comme ça
il peut aussi prendre mais quand il
prend créer une petite menace ici une
tension sur le cahier des 5 donc
attention et dans ton FC8 il fait ça
ouais ça j'aime bien laisse les blancs
se dépatouiller
bien joué de la part de visite qui est
un peu plus lent que son adversaire avec
une 0,4 pour une 45 pour notre mvl
national mais il joue très solidement et
il y a aucun problème sur la position
mais attention il faut pas se mettre
trop mal au temps
alors comment on va faire ici avec les
Blancs pour essayer de maintenir
un semblant de pression Pranger cette
donne le choix en noir de prendre ces
cinq intermédiaires et de reprendre le
cavalier et de jouer avec
tout doit se valoir ici ça peut pas
équilibré clairement
mais non il prend G7 et sur MD4 qui est
6 et ça reste très très solide tour
assez un peu tête d'amassi va arriver
d'âme 5 ok en détroit est un peu mieux
placé que le canard F6 mais bon c'est le
seul avantage
une belle pression en temps quand même
30 secondes c'est pas c'est pas anodin
comme avant son temps
et il va falloir qu'il nous fasse des
tours de magie notre ami Maxime cavalier
4 il s'organise autour de ce cavalier
peut-être dame 5 à suivre de cavalier
des 5 40 secondes pour visite changer
d'armes évidemment ça serait tellement
plus simple à jouer cette position avec
les sans lesdames sur les chéquier dame
5 à mon avis mesdames 5 dames c'est 5
comment on fait dame 5 jouer d'un de ces
5 va très probablement arriver
proposant encore une fois un échange de
dames je crois qu'il va pas pouvoir être
évité cette fois quoique pardon donc
dame C7 la même idée
et ça va être complexe de poser les
questions noires c'est quand même une
position symétrique sans les dames ça va
être dur si on fait d'un E3 d'amser 5 on
continue le harcèlement non il garde les
dames 5 mais ça lui a coûté du temps
mais c'est là où il est bon dans le
mutuel là normalement il place une
petite combine au bon moment une convie
bien senti bien calculer surtout et tour
des 8 visite qui continue à jouer très
très solide et il veut garder les pièces
attention à pas trop en faire non plus
parce que là on donne la colonne pour
rien
et 35 secondes chacun alors attention
mais il joue la gagne clairement Maxime
il refuse tous les échanges il essaie de
compliquer à fond la position cahier des
trois menace KFC 5 il tourne un peu 30
secondes chacun ça va être très chaud B5
un petit peu affaiblissant mais ma foi
c'est pas très grave à 4 certainement
non il fait tourner cinq d'abord il veut
doubler sur la colonne C
peut-être pour C8 pour essayer
d'échanger les pièces et 20 secondes
pour visiter c'est bon vas-y réfléchis
et non Dame des quatre il essaie
d'échanger les dames là cette fois je
crois que c'est accepté
j'ai l'impression peut-être tours c'est
un
et on est chargé à nos conditions non et
il prend d'abord
tu reprends on va arriver
tout reprend on va arriver tours c'est
un cahier des cinq et visite toujours
aussi solide très très légère avantage
blanc mais franchement pas assez
normalement pour créer une décision la
tour c'est 600 chatouiller chatouilleux
en les pions noirs il y a que ça
chatouiller et puis on a le dame
donc faut le faire allez un petit coup
du retour et attention ça commence à
être actif tout ça peut-être thoraciste
menace tour des 7 une tour sur la 7e
c'est déjà ça
et la jauge qui aime beaucoup Maxime ça
y est oh il a gagné on a rien vu on a
rien vu
il a été énorme là il est il est gagné
en probablement puis on prend enfin au
moins un pion de plus
c'était la perceptible ce qu'il a fait
mais il a fait de grandes choses là il a
donné
il a fait tourner en bourrique
ou non il revient ici cavalier F6
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire un petit coup
droit G2
et oui ça marche pas de pain tomber
amène on va faire tour à 7 je suppose
une fois de plus ou pas 8 secondes
il protège mes tours 5 maintenant puis
en plus et la tour sur un septième
rangée ça a l'air gagnant pour Maxime
qui a fait des miracles là on s'est en
quelle technique il est fort
il est fort et par contre l'ordinateur
ne suit plus
voilà c'est suffit du tout la
mince alors il y a un problème oh là là
c'est terrible
je vais essayer de refresh mais
et voilà on en est là on en est là il a
gagné la deuxième pion on regardera ça
au ralenti depuis on avance pour ma mvl
attention attention à pas se prendre une
combinette mais c'est deux pions
est-ce qu'on perd pas celui-là un 4
contre 3 alors certes il est très
plaisant mais c'est pas terminé
prendre le pion
en 4 et sur quel il prend deux le
cavalier complètement dominé la tour
la tour
ça a été grandiose qu'il a fait regardez
comment il nous a tricoté ça on en était
là et là franchement la plupart des
joueurs auraient dit nul
mais
petit à petit de manière c'est même pas
facile de je trouve de pointer du doigt
l'erreur des Noirs tellement ça a été
petit à petit et vous voyez ces pions là
déjà qui était déjà commencé à être mal
en point peut-être fait jouer à 4 ici
c'est pas un choix facile on comprend
vite qui a voulu donner un pion pour
s'activer
et petit à petit il a fait son chemin
et attaque ici et c'est le deuxième pion
déjà tours c'est de québecca de petit
tactique voilà c'est là où il a une
technique parfaite c'est-à-dire que ces
séquences de deux trois coups il les
calcule parfaitement
et maintenant il protège sur ton prends
E2 vous voyez à Rouen F3 encore une
combinette c'est pas très compliqué mais
de les répéter comme ça sans faire
d'erreurs de calcul c'est ça qui est
très dur
et voilà il a continué
et là il fallait quand même il fallait
quand même oui enfin moi je n'en plus
j'ai pas vu la tour qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait faire ici qui est des 4 est une
gaffe fallait faire tout à deux
et se venger sur ce pion et on avait un
4 contre 3 évidemment très difficile
pour les Noirs mais il a fait ça et sur
4K
et bam la tour
alors
est-ce que tout est
les parties sont terminées on va aller
voir tout de suite les résultats la
prochaine ce sera un gamer
et grishou a battu
gokesi et ml comme on l'a vu abattu
vidéo
et PRAC contre gamer
1-0 au 6 0 1 et la bonne nouvelle elle
va être là au classement une remontée
de Maxime machin grave qui est
maintenant quatrième execo Prague
Caracol toujours en tête si ronde à
jouer
il reste si on
et il est à trois points du leader ça va
être compliqué greachuk 8 et demi 9 pour
Prague
clairement
clairement ça ça se joue à rien Abdou
satorov si c'est demi et là c'est là où
c'est beaucoup plus serré vite le
perdant contre
qui a été qui vient d'être vaincu par
mvl à 6 points execo avec mvl et air
gazy donc ça sera très chaud pour la
troisième place c'est vrai qu'une
première et une troisième place ça
serait quand même pas mal on va tout de
suite changer son score il assiste sur
12 notre ami mvl et c'est que 50% mais
c'est pas loin de la troisième place
donc ça va mieux ça va mieux pour mvl
effectivement la première place pareil
quand même beaucoup trop loin
on va tourner les chéquier
gamer versus mvl je vais vous montrer
oui tout à fait les appareils on va
faire ça
et
et non Maxime qui a deux sur trois
aujourd'hui donc c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal du tout
alors on parlait des tournois français
bah écoutez ou européen ouais
européen en Espagne il y a pas mal de
temps il faut regarder du côté de
l'Espagne il y a des tours très sympa
notamment à Barcelone
ça a été ça a été dit dans le chat la
montagne en été c'est sympa elle peut
durer c'était très bien il faisait pas
trop chaud on était bien
voilà mais il y a tellement de tournois
en France n'hésitez pas à regarder après
c'est dur à dire trois préférés
il fait beau les gens sont sympas c'est
très très sympa à l'Islande ouais
l'Islande en mars effectivement
quand c'est trop bien et oui
pas que pas que
après
ça joue c'est à droite
non c'est l'écriture
en anglais
oui
mais bon c'est pas très grave vous
comprenez tout le monde comprend
Rick en mars très bonne oui les
conditions de jeux sont quand même assez
assez dingue
effectivement
l'île de Man très très beau tournoi ce
grand Suisse mais alors le temps
c'est quelque chose en plus j'y suis
allé quand même quelques fois
alors mvl vide mvl vient de l'emporter
très très important
alors pourquoi j'ai vu une question tout
à l'heure pourquoi il y avait
pourquoi il y avait
autant dire tout simplement ça même et
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a tellement
tellement de jeunes joueurs indiens
prometteurs que c'est dommage de pas
tous ces invités
et encore on aurait pu ajouter ça rime
dans ce tournoi mais bon ils vont pas
faire un tournoi non plus contre indien
il y a déjà la moitié de joueurs indiens
donc il y a pas de calife c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment
bon vouloir de l'organisateur
allez mvl il est troisième non il est
quatrième pardon mais quatrième execo
avec trois joueurs c'est très serré et
un demi point de la troisième place
et il aura les Noirs contre gamer
dans cette prochaine partie
qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre
d'intéressant Prague et joue Abdou et
grid show qui joue airgazy ok
Maxime donc on est pourri de choc
voilà on vise clairement
clairement
la troisième place
ça a commencé
WLF superplay
Laurent Blanc a répondu MVN
bien sûr
Laurent Blanc va démissionner ou à
démissionner je sais pas
pour s'occuper d'un VL
alors
il reste il reste six partis pour
aujourd'hui et tout se joue c'est sur 12
18 rondes on joue contre 9 autres
joueurs blancs et noir voilà on est à au
tiers des matchs retours
donc ça paraît
ça paraît beaucoup mieux parti pour la
troisième place après cette victoire
contre vidite parce que sinon ça
semblait compliqué en début de journée
et les choses sont en train de
s'améliorer les prochaines parties dans
trois minutes
ah ouais il y a des gens qui croient
encore il a trois points de retard il
est parti
ça paraît dur d'imaginer une première
place quand même pour être très honnête
il faudrait vraiment même
mathématiquement ça semble cuit
non non c'est pas raisonnable il y a
deux joueurs en plus donc là c'est
vraiment c'est le podium qu'on vise
non ça a commencé à 10h30 sur changer
l'horaire fallait bien écouter hier
ça commence à 10h30 on va airghisy qui
s'assoit donc ça sera pas léché qui est
le Maxime
Maxime non ça c'est à 12 ans
toujours pas de Maxime
et Maxime est là face au numéro 1
allemand Vincent gamer
top 3 ouais ça c'est déjà une grosse
perf parce que il était au fond quoi que
il est quand même un peu revenu sur la
fin mais bon
c'est une blague un peu d'explication
pour Laurent Blanc on n'arrête pas de
demander qui est notre nouvelle
entraîneur de Maxime donc j'en ai eu
marre maxime est en fan de
l'Olympique Lyonnais
je suis Laurent Blanc
puis en plus il est en il s'est fait
virer ou pas encore
le chômage
non
je sais pas qui suis ça de près
la dernière fois que j'ai vu c'est qu'il
allait se faire virer en gros
ouais c'est vrai qu'il a fait un début
de tournoi à zéro sur 3 effectivement
alors Maxime qui va entamer cette partie
contre gamer
je crois qu'il l'a battu hier c'est sa
première victoire
alors ces quatre jouets par gamer voici
bien aujourd'hui il joue pas des
adversaires qui essaient de l'attraper
dans l'ouverture avec les Blancs c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle
et voilà il joue une nage d'enfant en
premier si on joue des 5 c'est une nage
d'orf mec un temps de plus pour les
blancs
et oui il relève le challenge il a
tellement l'habitude de se positions
et revient en F6 ok c'est logique on va
mettre le fou par là je suppose pas sur
pas sûr il réfléchit mais
oui clairement c'est pas du tout un
essai de
prise de gros avantage disons avec les
Blancs
sans nos pièces
et certainement un coup de petit rock un
coup de fou 3 mais pas très ambitieux la
part des blancs
allez Maxime il commence à réfléchir
gamer
alors comment on va faire ici
il réfléchit très bien
bon là j'ai l'impression il réfléchit
pas pour grand oh là là Maxime qui a
regardé les autres parties
en confiance dans ce deuxième jour
et sur food 3 il fait fou B6 Maxime va
chez Lagrave
comme prévu on n'a pas envie de prendre
le droit et de renforcer le centre blanc
et connaissez position par cœur Maxime
parce que normalement il les joue
couleur inversé
si il se lève là c'est énorme
on va venir là faire pression sur ce
pion peut-être prendre du cavalier en B6
et d'abord
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire ça là pour
forcer un échange il paraîtrait
intéressant
attention les choses comme ça aussi il
faut prendre avec et j'ai 4 ça peut
aller très vite parfois
ça peut être très vite pour les noirs
il réfléchit là il hésite entre eux OK
du coup très solide très classique il se
passe pas grand chose
mais les joueurs qui ont déjà dépensé
une minute ou quasiment
alors maintenant comment fait-on est-ce
qu'on prend le 3 et G4 est-ce que ça
marche ou pas
calcul ce genre de choses ça c'est
évident
ça a pas l'air
ouais il prend quand même OK
donc faut que ça soit combiné avec G4
c'est combiné avec G4 et sur qui c'est 4
on va certainement faire
semblent être le seul coup pour pas
perdre moi qui non
on va voir que c'est 4 ans semble être à
quoi il réfléchit qu'il est mort
et afficher à B5 H3
puis on prend puis on prend puis on
prend ah non
cavalier en prise mais on peut quand
même prendre ici c'est chaud
mais quand il a fait chier gamer là
pardon pardon
j'avais pas vu il fait quelle C4
finalement et Maxime fait faux aussi
parce que B5 avait pas l'air bon du tout
pardon je retourne chez qui
il menace vous pensez 4 clairement sur
H3 on fait full prend je prends et on
revient
et on est très bien
allez ça serait bien chez victoire là il
a 30 secondes d'avance et il est bien il
va prendre ses 4 et puis on prend il va
revenir aussi et voilà et voilà la
structure de pion complètement sur tous
ces pions là ce pion là est très faible
mais même pas obligé d'essayer de s'en
occuper tout de suite parce que fougère
ça donnerait du jeu sur F7 peut-être
dame B3
pas trop de questions
dame prend G5 dame B3 attaque F7 attaque
B7
en tour B8 en protège et puis on baise 7
et il prend F3 ouais ça c'est le risque
quand même
et là je n'aime pas du tout
alors B5 va arriver pour se venger sur
le pur c'est 7
[Musique]
j'aime pas du tout là
j'aime pas du tout
je trouve qu'il s'est mis il a donné
trop de jeux là non seulement ça a pas
l'air très bon pour lui mais en plus ça
devient facile à jouer pour gamer qui
est quand même beaucoup moins de temps
c'est un peu dommage tout ça
alors qu'il avait quand même des
coussins à jouer il n'a pas besoin
d'aller se jeter sur ce pion sa fillette
me prend ces trois je suis peut-être
Tour Eiffel pour menacer des choses
méchantes sur la 8e ou pas
il faut s'organiser autour de ce pion
aussi
cette prise en C6 c'est jouer 39
secondes simplement pour gamer puis on
prend puis on prend
et attention il y a beaucoup de jeux 33
secondes contre une minute c'est
bouillante ici on a envie de faire la
petite case quand même
peut-être que G6 aussi contrôle cette
case mais à cette fuite
non mais c'est pas toi fuite mais bon
menace de menacer H6 jouer par mvl qui
se fait une petite case de sortie ça
peut être utile en temps voulu
pour l'instant il est vaincu aujourd'hui
Maxime 20 secondes simplement pour gamer
il va falloir qu'il se dépêche
il propose un échange de deux tours pour
la dame alors l'ordi aime pas mais en
pratique ça peut être très très dur à
jouer avec le roi dans les courants
d'air
et le cavalier oui qui va être un très
beau bloqueur ici sur la colonne F qui a
menacé de sauter par là aussi
un petit échec
et cavalier F6 qui va arriver
et puis on va
il y a plus de cases ou c'est le casse
certainement alors attention à ton F3 le
coup du retour c'est très chaud 40
secondes 45 secondes contre 14
il peut l'emporter la maintenant
D6 pour contrôler la case F7 aussi
c'est ce qui va faire peut-être tour et
fuite ici on s'infiltre meilleur ROI G7
et on dit oust
et comment on va faire ici H5 peut-être
pour jouer G5 G4 attaqué avec les pions
est-ce que ça va être fait ou pas
il faut qu'il se dépêche 5 qui
apparemment est un mauvais coup mais
tout F3 comment on fait maintenant pour
protéger spion je vois pas de solution
honnêtement
je n'en vois pas
ça prend l'eau là mais bon cette seconde
pour gamer on prend l'eau mais on a du
temps
ouh là là gamer gamer gamer qui a joué
avec 6 secondes OK
et il est gagnant gamer là il a pris
spion les tours sont activent le roi est
bien protégé par son fou
c'est dur là pour Maxime on est dans le
dur
et tomber deux pour venir avec la tour
en B6
c'est terminé je pense
c'est malheureusement ah sinon sur ton
B6 il va essayer de caser un perpète
comme ça avec Dame j'ai 5 damg3
mais bon tout rêve de le coup du retour
et comment on fait maintenant
elle est très dur à jouer cette position
faut espérer un miracle allez le
cavalier Blitz le Cayan G5
j'ai l'impression ou pas en tout cas
c'est une bonne chance de tenir
cette partie qui est ici s'empêche des
quatre parce qu'elle Pione qui est en
prise kb7 il va lancer 5 et il va
attaquer spion et sur des cas maintenant
on revient au F3 le roi doit rester ici
menacer chèque B26 aussi encaisse le
plus rare il a fait de la magie avec son
cavalier Maxime Vacher la grave il est
énorme il est énorme il peut plus perdre
maintenant il a gratté le pion à B2K et
là il lui donne le tournis et cavaliers
F2 qui va arriver qui a été un va être
joué non à 4 d'abord bien joué bien joué
à 4 d'abord ouh là que c'est chaud
et prend le 3 et sur D5 en met le roi en
D6 et ensuite on fait j'ai 5 G4 ça a
l'air complètement gagnant ou j'ai 5
d'abord
est-ce que j'ai 5 d'abord ou 7 il
calcule ça mvl Roissy d'abord pas de
contre-jour roi V3 roi V8 fr G5
maintenant
et c'est bien joué 4 c'est gagnant
incroyable roi C5 on aura roi des 8 de
toute façon on gagne une pièce est-ce
qu'on gagne la partie faut faire
attention à ce que le roi ne puisse pas
prendre tous les pions mais je crois pas
que ce soit possible
roi C6 maintenant il est encaisse ici il
va jouer que j'ai deux cavalie F4 il va
s'organiser sur le plan H3 oh c'est une
gaffe
c'est une gaffe apparemment maintenant
c'est nul
parce qu'il y a ces deux pions qui
arrivent comment on fait ici avec les
Noirs ok j'ai 5 si on reprend H3 on
gagne comment on fait nul le ranger 4
peut-être et ranger 3 oh là là quel
dommage et maintenant il va pas pouvoir
prendre le Pione parce qu'il y aura
toujours des sept
ah là là ça va faire nul bon ça soit pas
si mal
tram mince alors mince alors mais
regardez-moi ça comment ça gagner ici G4
3D 8 3c6 puis on prend puis on prend et
là il a fait que j'ai deux un qui est le
coup de Blitz mais apparemment c'est pas
du tout le bon coup on va regarder il
fallait jouer oh là là c'est joli ouais
mais c'est trop dur c'est trop dur pour
un public il fallait jouer cavalier G4
sachant que c'est pas prenable parce
qu'on va faire dame
et on voit les ici avec le roi et le roi
des cinq on fait quoi
sur roi des 5 on fait roi des 7
magnifiques zigzangues et surpuis on
prend on fait H3 en fait ce cavalier
n'est pas en prise on doit bouger le
cavalier le roi et maintenant cavalier
F6 gentiment on va encaisser ce pion le
roi doit bouger d'abord on va prendre ce
pion on prend tout ce qu'on veut
ok ok j'ai 4 et quand même est quand
même un coup dur à trouver
alors on va voir s'il y a une autre
partie en cours et non il y a pas
d'autres parties en cours on va aller
voir les résultats c'est il nous a fait
de la magie c'est pas mal quand même
c'est pas mal on s'en sort bien on va
pas pleurer on va pas pleurer on
croirait quand on est français si on
pleurait sur ce résultat
parce que franchement au vu de la partie
s'en sort quand même plutôt bien cette
décision là de donner le fou et tu es
pas bonne
mais après il nous a fait un truc avec
son cavalier il a été énorme
les résultats à tous Prague ah ça se
resserre
nul contre Raja bof gamer MVN nul et
goket abattu vidite ça s'est bien pour
nous
enfin qu'il perde tout simple pour que
ça soit bien pour nous et on a un
classement qui se resserre voilà s'il
avait gagné il a pas été loin de rien
Prague avec neuf vous voyez ça va très
vite dans les Bleus c'est quand même
incroyable
8 et demi pour
7,5
et Maxime avec si c'est le mi-vidite à 6
qui fait un peu de sur place
dernièrement de les autres 5 et demi 5
et 3 et demi donc Maxime vous voyez pas
loin du tout
est-ce que roi C8 on va regarder d'abord
les appareils
non non
la prochaine
est-ce que roi C8 gagner maximum elle
est blanc contre Google
on va essayer de répondre aux questions
est-ce que roi C8 gagner ou pas
en Espagne
alors j'ai 4
je mets ma petite jauge
et on va C8 gagner aussi exactement mais
il a même idée
que j'ai quatre encore une fois
et moi aussi ce cavalier 2 bref
5 et j'ai 5 ah le pion est trop poussé
maintenant
moi j'ai quatre H3 j'ai 3 et maintenant
on reprend
allez on va se mettre sur google
et je vais faire une petite pause une
petite pause ça commence dans 6 minutes
donc je reviens en trois quatre minutes
pour le début de cette partie on va voir
si Maxime va chez
accrocher un podium restez avec moi pour
suivre tout ça à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus adieu du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les titles
chess.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour pour suivre
ces cinq derniers Blitz
de la du tournoi et de la journée
ce beau statistiques India
qui
qui va se conclure
aujourd'hui
on avait vaccin c'est bon on a retrouvé
Maxime et
voilà Maxime qui a les blancs contre
goûtech la nouvelle star indienne 17 ans
simplement mais déjà tellement fort
allez Maxime qui joue qui joue un podium
là clairement
et ça serait très beau après une
première place en rapide il a clairement
ma très mal commencé avec 0 sur 3 une
première journée très hésitante mais ça
va mieux là un vaincu aujourd'hui
un vaincu pour le moment
et une belle remontée au classement
allez
et des quatre jouets donc ils changent
ils jouent un peu tous les coups
chercher à s'amuser Nimzo avec E3 ok
pourquoi pas
le 3 fous des deux c'est très solide
pour les blancs et pour les Noirs
d'ailleurs
le cavalier par là et on va essayer de
d'attaquer avec F4 ça peut être assez
agressif ce genre de choses
y réfléchit Maxime on peut commencer
aussi par ton S1 ici
beaucoup de coups intéressants
des trois on fait x 6 normalement 3 8
d'abord
et sur petit roc ou il fait fout des 6
ok il connaît son histoire il empêche
cavalier 5 peut-être qu'il y avait 5 ici
pour chasser le fou
toujours intéressant de faire ça
on va voir mais déjà 30 secondes de
moins pour mvl qui ben voilà son
adversaire encore une fois mieux préparé
dans ce Blitz et c'est important c'est
40 secondes du départ
ça peut jouer des tours
il improvise la maxime clairement
un petit coup de H3 bon je sais pas trop
à quoi ça sert mais bon pourquoi pas ça
fait une petite case
il est clairement pas familier avec ce
genre de position
x 6 x 6 ou B7 on va faire à 6 kbd7 et
c'est 5 dans le bon tempo
toujours faire attention sur ton serre
le coup automatique c'est à 6 pour
empêcher kbb5 vous allez voir tour c'est
un A6 va être joué rapidement c'est
jouer
parkesh et ensuite c'est très compliqué
pour les blancs si on n'a pas de
cavalier 5 dans les tuyaux
très compliqué de faire un plan ici
moi-même j'ai été confronté à plusieurs
reprises avec les Blancs pas évident ça
va pas être facile avec moins de moins
de 2 minutes là pour inventer un nouveau
plan
et cavalier F4 oui certes mais bon c'est
ça pas grand chose peut-être fou c'est 3
alors les blancs sont probablement pas
moins bien quoi que la jauge semble
indiquer le contraire
et c'est 5 et voilà tout est logique
pour les noirs et on a ces pions pendant
mais plutôt une bonne version pour les
Noirs comment on fait ici pousser trois
il y a toujours des D4 attention à ce
cavalier qui est un peu en l'air comme
on dit
c'est pas facile ici
ça peut les deux fous braquer sur le
rock vous voyez là
ça peut aller très vite selon l'histoire
des quatre jouets très vite par Google
attention je crois que déjà tourgé 5 il
menace il y a plus de tourger 5 ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle
comment on fait maintenant
il faut bouger la tour alors est-ce
qu'il va le garder la tour sur la 5e où
est-ce qu'il va revenir en 8 gentiment
ça sera le match de speech de lundi
entre les deux joueurs
et il prend son temps un petit peu
Google ça fait du bien parce que là il
jouait vraiment très très vite pour 8 il
revient c'est le coup complètement
standard
comment on fait ici avec les Blancs on
doit se battre faut faire attention à ce
fou un voyou qui rayonne quand même sur
cette grande diagonale
il est très très dangereux ce fou très
bien placé
qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant
peut-être un petit coup un petit coup de
centralisation et cavalier E4 qui est
des 5 aussi il semble raisonnable
bref les Noirs au minimum un minimum
aucun problème
quoi que il est 5 on peut prendre et
jouer KFC il décide de prendre un F4 ok
de jouer de 6 on va revenir certainement
et sur Dame des cinq on aura un petit
souci sur G2 c'est ça qui m'inquiétait
Maxime oui qui est du moins bon côté de
la position égale clairement
et dure à jouer sa position
faut pas la perdre
ah ça une défaite un mettrait un coup de
frein à sa remonter là
si jamais bon de perdre croyez moi
ok il protège ce cavalier surtout
empêcher la dame de venir là c'est tout
à fait logique et un petit coup de G6 et
oui c'est fou
qui pouvait créer des petits problèmes
le coût du pro G6 peut-être même droit
G7 maintenant
et qu'on va faire comment on va faire
ici avec les noirs pour essayer
d'accentuer la pression c'est pas
évident et une case il a rattrapé son
retour si on prend ici on peut pas se
jeter sur ce four cavalier prend ça va
pas il fait des trois il dit ok
pour les change mais dans mes conditions
c'est-à-dire tu me remets le cavalier en
Détroit si tu veux changer
et tout recettes va venir ici
apparemment c'est une gaffe il y a un
truc tactique là non c'était pas ça
c'est parce que c'était
quoi que peut-être c'est pas un truc
tactique qui considère en fait que
maintenant le pion a est faible
ok il aime bien les il aime bien les
blancs maintenant l'ordinateur et bien
c'est imperceptible une fois de plus
ça crée Maxime il va bien
aussi pour mettre la pression sur le
pion des
intéressant
et surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est
que Google je sais pas si derrière
autant
autour des 8 très logique on met la tour
derrière le pion passé
ah ça y est ça commence à chatouiller sa
chatouille si sa chatouille par là aussi
il a voulu garder ça donc sur des trois
des trois assemble
menace c'est pas mal aussi protège le
pion j'avais pas vu du tout et 3 ok on
va jouer la petite finale maintenant on
est content les petites finales
tout simplement parce que on a cette
majorité à une dame
potentiellement on a un pur passé
éloigné ça peut être pas mal pour les
blancs
5 la petite finale ça y est
il est mal Google ça y est d'un coup
incroyable
le magicien
ça crée un VL qui est des trois le coup
du retour
cherche mieux est-ce qu'il y a mieux je
suis pas sûr mais peut-être
mais en tout cas il a stabilisé sa
position et donc il a un avantage ça
c'est très clair
qu'il y ait des trois tours C7 et vas-y
que je te remets le fond F3 il serait
organise Maxime il est un peu mieux le
cavalier bloqueur le fameux ce pion est
faible ce pion est aussi une faiblesse
pas évidente à jouer cette position
surtout ces deux on dit
oust ou pas non et 8 secondes simplement
pour goûtech cavalier F4 c'est vraiment
c'est le ballet du cavalier
pour éviter ce qu'on va faire attention
c'est on s'écrit là ouais il va mettre
l'autre tour quoi que non ça perdrait le
pion
tourner dans l'attaque le pion tour des
7 peut-être fougères peut-être F3 donc
il est 3 d'abord le bail qui est C5 il
embêtait certainement et ça y est il a
réussi à tout faire
à faire ce qu'il avait envie de faire F5
faut prendre non ça gagne pas un pion
c'est un fou prends un cake c'est 5 je
croyais que ça gagnait un pion
des six tours prend des cartes là
peut-être et cavaler aussi est-ce que ça
joue ça il est en train de calculer
c'est sûr non il a estimé que c'était
trop dangereux
et maintenant il revient un peu c'est la
panique à bord vous cache qui est en
train à améliorer sa position cavaluer
attaque le pion une nouvelle fois tour
d'essai le coup du retour peut-être le
coup du retour aussi parce que là on
serait pas mécontents de la nul et non
il est pas content il annule il fait
froid de
et sur cavalier aussi ce qu'on va faire
maintenant attention à cavalier F4 ce
cavalier très bien placé ou le pion F5
joue gave tout vous voyez quand ces
joueurs là il me resterait pas beaucoup
de pièces à la fin du die note je vous
le dis
ce pion là contre ce pion là est-ce que
c'est un bon troc ça a pas l'air
terrible B3 peut-être mais 3 et à 5 vous
me direz non il a pris
ah c'est pas un bon troc maintenant la
tour qui vient s'infiltrer cahier des
trois menaces attention
il a l'oeil ou cache
des 7 menaces de prendre peut-être et
c'est à peu près égal plus de kss-5
maintenant ou cavalier 4 ok attention à
ce pion maintenant c'est le roi va venir
oui comme The King
autour des 5 ok fousser si c'est
potentiellement pas être bien avec les
Blancs il y a les pions faibles et un
pion pas s'éloigné mais ce fou est quand
même très fort
les trois résultats sont possibles
et vas-y pousse moi ça tu as raison on
la faute six énormes gaffe qui laisse
tout le jeu à Maxime en fout des 5 B5 et
oui tour C5 maintenant non
mais non ton C5 gagner aimer la tour
derrière il est bon réflexe Maxime ça
doit gagner ça aussi B6 et roi des trois
maintenant ça va être gagnant
il fait F3 G3 là pour empêcher tout
contre le jeu F4 G4 bien sûr 4 va être
joué quoi d'autre
va certainement être joué tomber 5 c'est
du zigzang ça y est il est en zigzang
sur des trois il y a tour B4 et on va
encaisser le pion et on est complètement
gagnant oh là là tour de magie de Maxime
Vacher Lagrave incroyable ce qu'il a
fait il peut abandonner Google ses yeux
pour pleurer dans cette finale et
victoire de Maxime Vacher La Grave
incroyable
on est d'accord que ça ça gagnait
on est d'accord moi il me semble que
tous ces cinq là quand même c'était pas
mal
ton C5 + 3 et oui la fameuse finale de
pion on se cassait pas la tête
et voilà on fait je sais pas F3 par
exemple pour apprendre mes 5 rois
prendre les quatre et on va manger toute
la funky family alléluia
tandis que sur vous prend ouais c'était
gagnant aussi tu reprends la tour
derrière il est bon réflexes Maxime et
ça gagne facile on va aller voir
peut-être s'il y a pas et non c'est tout
est terminé Maxime qui aura les Noirs
dans la prochaine contre Nandy bec Abdou
satorov on va aller voir les résultats
les résultats visite maximum abattu
goket
qui fait une deuxième journée il est en
feu Abdou sa torov
il est clairement en feu
il vient de Bad gamer
et le
classement avec
Maxime Vacher la grave cette ennemi sur
qui est quatrième execo avec Easy Abdou
ça torov qui revient comme un boulet de
canon il reste cinq parties
il reste quatre parties pardon 4 parties
quatre parties et il a que deux points
de moins sur le premier alors ça serait
remontée
assez incroyable mais peu probable quand
même on va pas se mentir
of a priori ça se jouera entre ces trois
là pour la victoire finale
tandisky et Maxime sont quand même très
très bien pour la troisième place aussi
ils peuvent revenir ils sont quand même
point ah non
là une update donc il a 8 ans il a 7 et
demi on sait pas ça s'en va et ça
revient
et on va update ça ça fait plaisir de
voir Maxime à plus de 50% c'est la
première fois du tournoi
c'était une mission 14 alors ça reste
encore
pas le score qu'on espérait mais ça
devient de mieux en mieux évidemment
cette émission 14 pour Maxime qui aura
les Noirs attention il va essayer
d'attraper dans la voiture donc là c'est
une grosse partie si le rattrape
s'il le va et bien il le rattrape c'est
que la même histoire qu'avec visite tout
à l'heure donc une victoire
rapprocherait du podium très clairement
ferait au moins troisième ex aequo
ouais ça va être beau ça va être beau on
va voir important parce que regarde
aussi c'est la première place donc les
deux joueurs concentrés sur leur
objectif
et à 12 ans va certainement prendre des
risques
pour essayer d'aller chercher Prague et
greatchouk donc ça peut donner une
partie explosive une nage d'orf un truc
comme ça quoi
est-ce que les joueurs est-ce que ça a
fait une prépa spéciale Blitz
certainement
ouais gros match pour le podium une nul
nulle et pas grave une défaite
une défaite ça serait compliqué de
revenir ensuite une victoire serait
magnifique parce qu'elle permettrait de
rattraper déjà le podium et de rêver
plus grand
alors la dotation du temps c'est
tout simplement regarder ça
on va regarder ça est-ce que
info programme
résultat info
les prix et donc les prix c'est du
voilà et après il forme de 41000 dollars
dans chaque section
d'accord
donc ça veut dire
donc on sait pas exactement en fait en
vrai
en vrai on sait pas
on sait pas du tout quels sont les prix
exacts mais 41 000 dans chaque dans
chacun des tournois plus probablement
caché de départ comme on dit donc ça
fait 80 000 en tout
et à 40 000
on met combien on met normalement en
normand mais 25 30 % au premier
donc 30% de 40 000 pour les maths ça
fait une dizaine de mille
d'accord
avant ou après un pot
c'est quoi c'est les Anglais
qui
de chaussures dans la vie
la mort et les impôts
donc c'est
douzaine de mille ouais on sait pas
exactement 12 ans 2000 bon ben on
s'inquiète pas des belles conditions
évidemment les joueurs sont respectés
dans ces tournois et c'est très bien
comme ça évidemment
qui nous régal ouais et oui ça sera
l'île de Man le grand Suisse il peut se
qualifier aux candidat pas dans ce
tournoi évidemment mais c'est bon pour
la confiance évidemment d'avoir gagné ce
droit de partir rapide ça reste dans les
mémoires quand on va ce genre de joueur
et qu'on gagne un tournoi de ce niveau
et ouais il va faire 10 ouais ouais
c'est ça 10 12 +
ce prix là alors bon ça sera jamais un
podium ça sera jamais moins de 5 6
et donc oui ça fait un beau prix plus si
on compte un petit un petit cachet de
départ
ça fait
ça fait un petit déplacement sympa
voilà
c'est normal
c'est tout à fait normal
quand on voit on va pas commencer à
quand on revoit quand ça parle de foot
là les transferts de l'été bon c'est
quand même c'est autre chose
mon record hello est de 2720
publié sur 2700s
voilà donc aux alentours de 1720
top 100 peut-être pas
tous les joueurs du Top 100 peuvent
vivre que des tournois attention
pas typiquement il y a des gens comme
moi qui font d'autres choses à côté
voilà
moi je pourrai pas vivre que du jeu
Maxime vit que du jeu
pas nombreux à vivre que du jeu en
France par exemple
Maxime Lagarde aussi fait que ça je
crois
mais après c'est un style de vie aussi
c'est de voyager et de faire beaucoup de
punch beaucoup de voyages
c'est différent
je vais ça quand j'étais jeune
et c'est plus facile aussi quand j'étais
j'en ai moins de concurrence en
l'occurrence là
là vous avez joué à l'Open il y a
en général pas mal de jours indiens qui
jouent pas mal
écoute salut amical
Lagarde je vis chichement malgré tout
pour ne pas être seul
tu vis tu vis ah non tu en plus
non voilà donc c'est
un choix mais Maxime Lagarde
comme comme moi ça va durer un temps de
vivre que du jeu
ça peut pas durer ça peut pas durer
toute la vie non plus Etienne il fait
des choses à côté
aussi
parce qu'à un moment où les voyages et
tout ça les open
on se lasse un petit peu aussi
tu fais cours privé payant tu considères
ça comme vive du jeu non pas du tout je
considère ça comme une activité annexe
comme le streaming vif du jeu c'est
vivre du jeu faire que des tournois
et d’apprendre les quatre une petite
ligne ok ça c'est très bien c'est
parfait il essaie pas du tout d'attraper
dans l'ouverture moi c'est toujours ce
qui me fait peur dans ses bits avec
Maxime où il est un peu
pareil trop monté sans répertoire il
improvise un peu trop à mon avis à mon
goût en tout cas à mon goût de
commentateurs supporters
allez tourner un ouais c'est quand même
travailler ça d'où ça te refait toujours
des petites lignes et dame B6 propose la
petite finale oh là là c'est pas beau et
puis on prend accepter à tempo c'est à
te connaître
la théorie
ah j'ai gagné une place
BCS actuellement tu es 99 si on croit
2700 chef j'étais 100e tour rond
au classement de septembre mais tant
mieux si les autres perdent des points
j'attends du coup je joue pas
peut-être que si je gagne place par jour
pas de beau
tous les joueurs qui perdent des points
là hop il me réponds
ça a pris 10 jours pour que j'aille une
place bon ben tant pis les 1000 jours
dans 1000 jours c'est bon c'est à moi
alors à 3 est-ce qu'on peut prendre le
pion ou pas
si on prend le pion on va se renfermer a
priori il y a quand même de fortes
chances que ça soit enfermé tout ça
tombez à de jouer oh c'est joli ça c'est
très joli en échange des cavaliers
pardon pardon pardon pardon j'ai arrêté
de faire des ouh c'est joli j'aime bien
très esthétique ce cavalier à deux on
est sûr de manger une des deux pièces
donc tout va bien
comment peut-on progresser un classement
sans jouer c'est une des anomalies du
classement et l'eau c'est à dire que
quand on joue pas
on ne perd pas de points par exemple
Garric qui est en train de jouer à
Saint-Louis en ce moment et bien si
besoin de partir longue demain il va
s'inscrire à un tournoi il apparaît avec
son élo de
2800 12 je crois
ce qui est probablement avec tout le
respect du hacking
ouais mais tu as un grand fan
qui est probablement pas son niveau
actuel
parce qu'il a pas joué depuis longtemps
justement donc c'est une des anomalies
du classement et l'eau c'est peut-être
la seule chose qui est fait
le seul gros défaut du classement hello
c'est quand on est inactif
on bouge pas ouais un bon client de 1812
ça fait bizarre de dire ça de la part de
à propos de Kasparov mais c'est
probablement le
le cas la réalité
il peut se qualifier à candidats oui il
faut jouer 30 parties dans l'année quand
même pour avoir cette qualife donc faut
qu'il se dépêche mais effectivement il
serait gros favori si mais maintenant
sachant que les joueurs en 2780 il peut
se qualifier au candidat à sport bon je
crois pas que ça soit dans ses projets
et une position très confortable pour
revenir à nos moutons de Maxime
j'aime bien ce qu'il a fait il est bien
au temps
prise sous ces deux est-ce que c'est bon
ça
ça peut être dans les tuyaux et ces
jouets on va prendre le pion central on
va donner celui-là mais c'est pas grave
parce qu'on aura fou point F3
et on est très bien dans cette finale
grâce à la structure de pion
et les pions centraux aussi
il va prendre un F3 il est quasi obligé
malheureusement si on avait pu garder
nos notre paire de fond on l'aurait fait
il va jouer aussi ce dessin il a une
très très belle structure il va jouer
aussi ce quasi certainement
je me suis avancé peut-être si c'est
vraiment le coup réflexe en blitz
aussi suite des cinq on améliore notre
structure on met une petite tour en C4
là et on commence à poser des questions
et réfléchis Maxime OK ou il garde les
fous grosse ambition de mvl et oui je
n'ai pas vu du tout c'est avec la finale
de tour il y a plus de chance de survie
pour les pour les blancs est-ce qu'ici
ce fou peut être mal placé on va faire
le 6 là quand même non on fait pas aussi
jamais
oh là là F6 oh là là j'avais pas vu
venir celui-là f63 F7 et peut-être faut
H6 pour attaquer ce pion
ok ok très très agressif de la part de
Maxime qui a 20 secondes d'avance à la
pendule il a bien raison il a
complètement réussi son ouverture et il
fait des choix très très agressifs
clairement il montre son intention de
d'en découdre
on va tout à fait rikikits
qui dit Forem un minimum de partie côté
oui à l'année oui c'est ça
c'est pas mal en vrai
37 c'est pas mal parce que 30 c'est pas
non plus
30 je trouve ça bien
ça semble c'est à peu près mon nombre de
parties donc je suis pas tout à fait
objectif j'ai à l'époque genre jouer
genre jouer genre jouer plus de 100 par
an mais là j'en joue une trentaine à peu
près peut-être un peu plus une
quarantaine
mais ouais pas plus pas plus on s'arrête
on s'arrête à 40 ça c'est sûr et
regardez cette structure qui est pas
bonne du tout
mais tout et toi de partir rapide et
tout ça c'est quand même différent
maintenant tour B3 en clou
et Maxime qui est toujours un peu mieux
dans cette finale avec 40 secondes on
connaît sa technique impeccable alors 4
il essaie de s'activer évidemment à d'où
ça tourne qu'est-ce qu'on fait on lui
dit altos sketch un jour on réussisse
peut-être et oui c'est jouer des cinq on
va aller nous roi des 7 mais ça prend la
caisse du roi c'est surtout ça qu'on
voulait
roi des 7 je suppose F5 fougères 7 ah B5
c'est bien joué sans garde la tour on va
faire F5 fougères
et attention on peut pas protéger comme
ça parce qu'il y a la tour qui surgirait
de l'autre côté c'est très dur à jouer
pour cette offre de moins et une
position inférieure et une position plus
dure à jouer quatre fougères 7 et sur
foudé 4 c'est F5 maths ah dommage il y a
pas tenter le petit piège faut que
j'essaie de comment il fait pour
protéger la douceur il est dans les
cordes complètement oh il s'est fait
outplay dans cette finale mais alors
main gauche pour Maxime Vacher la grave
ça tombe bien il est gaucher mais il a
joué main gauche et vas-y je t'encaisse
tous les pions elle dame et ce pion là
aussi va tomber c'est complètement
gagnant Master Class de mvl
qui a pris des risques avec ce f63 F7
c'était très beau c'était très très bien
joué j'ai pas du tout vu venir et il
joue fous ces trois pas de contre jeu
gagnant pas de contre-jour monastère
prend à 3 on veut surtout pas voir la
tour apparaître en C7 c'est encore une
fois le coup du pro le coût du champion
du monde de Blitz 2021 et là on comprend
pourquoi
il a gagné autant de tournois en blitz
et notamment ce fabuleux titre un titre
casse une vie attention sur tourado il y
a tombé deux qui gagnent et qui a
réfléchit à réfléchit et il abandonne
tout simplement et curé et que
réhabdouxator off on va aller voir une
autre partie très très grosse partie le
rattrape il le lip frog comme on dit on
va regarder peut-être greatchouk quelque
chose qu'on pourrait rattraper aussi
contre Prague Prague il faut absolument
aller voir ça évidemment qu'on va voir
ça
évidemment et ça y est quelque chose
contre Prague donc les choquer les Noirs
dans cette partie contre PRAC elle est
blanc qu'est-ce qui se passe final de
Tours les noirs sont bien d'après la
jauge et oui potentiellement il y a des
pions pas c'est lié ici regardez-moi ça
peut-être
et c'est 4 le pion qui font qui est
protégé par l'autre et le roi qui peut
venir alors effectivement il y a un pion
passé mais c'est pas suffisant
normalement allez
joue roi C6 ou 80 réfléchir parce que
c'est vraiment le coup
tomber un tour je suis dedans il a joué
tout la fuite c'est pas possible
c'est une erreur de retransmission
espérant qu'il rebouche sa tour elle est
mal placée sa tour c'est un enfer ça ils
nous font le coup
et on voit ça bouge qu'est-ce qui se
passe tour à 8 ok c'est les mauvais
coups mais c'est de la bonne position
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué
Prague il a l'air complètement foutu on
va essayer de se mettre à la vue du
dessus
tu as vu où on voit mieux non pas
celle-là c'est la 2 non c'est pas la 2
non plus hop là c'est celle là on va
essayer de voir mais on voit rien
on voit rien pour Grez de choqué on voit
pra qui a l'air énervé on voit les faire
passer lier et il épouse allez Sacha
c'est bien joué il a gagné il a gagné
Sacha greatchouk on va aller voir s'il y
a pas une autre partie et gris chou qui
rattrape je crois après au classement ça
va être très très chaud cette fin de
tournoi qui est-ce qu'on va voir on va
voir peut-être
ça nous intéresse aussi au plus haut
point pour notre classement
et il est où il est où il est là on se
met en mode VIP et on va changer les
pendules et regardez-moi ça ça Blitz ça
Blitz sablée avec les Blancs contre
bouquet avec les noirs
qui est mieux et pourquoi j'en sais rien
personne d'après la jauge dame B7 ça
c'est un gros gros choix grosse décision
on a les pions passer mais espion F qui
peut aller très très vite aussi
complexe complexe ça peut jouer sur
trois résultats quoique j'ai
l'impression que les Blancs quand même
avec les deux pions passés liés sont
quand même assez safe
on va faire B4 on va faire baisser 5 on
va faire ses 5 et on va sacrifier ce
four roi des 4 va être joué ici on
décale va être très probablement être
jouée sur ton G3 à faire fout des cinq
et vas-y je vais te pousser les pions
obligé c'est la course the race
allez
et recette elle coupe perdant
apparemment il y a B6
et oui mais c'est logique et vas-y je te
poussais pions F3 C6 F2 C7 et je fais
dans mon premier non il fait 3 ok ça
gagne aussi apparemment F2 on va prendre
quand il va faire goûter maintenant fou
F3 et oui en protège tout on va faire
ces 6 B7 c'est complètement gagnant
parce qu'on a le pion h aussi
pantalon comme disent les Russes
pantalon
pantalon un pion là un pion là pantalon
allez vas-y pousse ce pion assez
complètement gagnant maintenant avec ce
fou du béton on va ramener le roi
maintenant par là on va ramener le roi
et voilà et voilà il va faire un petit
coup droit là et tourgé vite il va aller
dominer la tour gentiment et vas-y que
je te pousse le pion
il y aura pas d'échec sur la colonne h
il va pousser évidemment
il a poussé on voit plus les coups mais
on voit on peut les deviner sur chéquier
et achète va être joué et abandon de
Google
s'il a l'air un petit peu ouais non
c'est fini
c'est fini le score de Maxime ça fait
plaisir on va le changer tout de suite
Maxime 8 et demi sur 15 il a été énorme
Master Class contre Abdou Master Class
en fin de tournoi RS3 rondes et on va
aller voir tout de suite les résultats
de la ronde et le classement
les résultats avec Maxime agraf qui bat
Google
14 autant pour moi autant pour moi on va
aller voir les résultats de la ronde 15
et la rendre 15 à Christine a battu
gamer mais ça c'est pas très important
pour le classement final
ensuite on a gretchouk qui bat Prague
Raja BOV qui va vite et reggaizi
agrave qui bat Abdou Sator et ça ça fait
plaisir et c'est quoi le classement et
c'est gris Tchoupi prend la tête avec 10
points
qui fait une moins bonne journée
clairement neuf et demi et mvl 8 et demi
et Abdou ça torof aussi 8h30 oh là là
trois cinq joueurs se tiennent à un
point et demi à trois rondes de la fin
alors peut-être ça ressemble à une
remontée incroyable la remontada de
Maxime là il est déjà troisième ex Aego
donc il est déjà sur le podium ça
s'arrête ici mais franchement on peut
viser plus haut
mais vérité dernier il avait 0 sur 3
évidemment qu'il était dernier mais non
mon ami du BTP qui en profite pour
reprendre son truc je n'ai je n'en crois
pas mes oreilles incroyable
il a décidé de venir profiter des
commentaires
allez qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
ronde il joue Eric easy ils sont tous
les deux à 8 et demi c'est très chaud
tandis que nos deux leaders joue contre
gamer allez gamer visite joue contre
Prague allez allez vite et comme ça ça
peut nous offrir deux rangs de folie
de rendre incroyables
si Maxime évidemment l'emporte
il y a l'emporte il reste encore trois
bits tout est possible dans ces trois
derniers bits 8 et demi sur 15 MVA la
mine turbo toujours invaincu aujourd'hui
et il est sûr de victoires consécutives
il a trois victoires
il a quoi trois victoires et trois nuls
je crois
non il a commencé à 4 c'est facile à
compter normalement il a commencé à 4
sur 9 et donc maintenant il a fait 4 et
demi sur 6
ça recommence dans 7 minutes je reviens
dans dernière pause 3-4 minutes je vais
râler sur mon ami du BTP pour lui dire
d'arrêter tout de suite
tu as arrêté de bosser le weekend
puis quoi encore le dimanche
allez on va voir on va voir ouais mais
là tout est ouvert parce que c'est à
droite ces joueurs sont fatigués il peut
se passer énormément de choses dans ces
Blitz série il va falloir gagner contre
Erika ici d'abord et déjà assurer
quasiment assurer le podium
on va suivre ça petite pause et je
reviens tout de suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs émoticônes et les
emojis disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
et je suis de retour pour ces
trois derniers
du tournoi et de la journée
et on a Maxime agrafe qui nous fait une
remontée là incroyable il est 3e execo
regardez-moi ça troisième execo à 8 et
demi simplement un point de mie de gris
de chou comme point de Prague oh là là
ça peut être ça peut être énorme
ça peut être énorme il faut espérer
maintenant faut sauter du mal aux autres
clairement
il est bien monté ouais ouais il est
clairement il est clairement remonté
incroyablement fort là
Maxime qui aura les blancs dans cette
partie on va voir ce qu'il va faire il a
joué ces quatre DK
allez Maxime
ouais ouais grichou qui est très solide
dans ce tournoi
pour moi
il a perdu très peu non non j'ai pas
abandonné j'ai vu ta question
ah j'aime pas ces questions
j'ai pas le droit d'abandonner j'ai
signé un contrat j'ai signé sans
réfléchir
c'est mon pire cauchemar arrêter de me
parler de ça je je je n'en dors plus
enfin si j'en dors quand même je dors
vous inquiétez pas
je dors
dors bien mais
c'est une petite angoisse quand même
c'est une épine dans le pied vous voyez
alors ça sera pas avant la fin de
l'année ça c'est sûr début du 24
j'espère je suis en retard je raconte
pas pour l'instant il râle pas trop
voilà pas je râle rien je serais pas
content
E4 et oui nous fait plaisir Maxime ça y
est ça joue l'or ça joue l'or et on joue
le 4 et B3 bon ça mouille un peu mais
c'est pas mal c'est une petite variante
qui existe B3 ou B2 sur ces sicilienne
hier de savoir ce qu'il fait
il joue très vite Maxime aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire x 2 ici et
petit rock et on a une position tout à
fait correcte avec certainement et puis
isolé plus tard foutez trois plus
agressif que faut deux
et un petit peu surprise c'est bon pour
nous ça
allez allez Maxime
et maintenant on va certainement jouer
le pion isolé qui est BD2 ensuite
peut-être qu'il est baisé de tout de
suite je sais pas
c'est très dur à dire comme il est beau
casse pas aujourd'hui j'en sais rien
j'en sais rien mais il joue pas mal il
joue pas mal on peut jouer très bien
comme beaucoup moins bien ça dépend de
sa fatigue
ça dépend de l'implication qui met dans
la dans dans le tournoi aussi la
préparation il fait beaucoup de choses à
côté on le sait il avait prédit winter
is coming
on avait malheureusement évidemment
les faits
les fait lui en donner raison il avait
raison il y avait 20 ans
exactement ce qui s'est en train de se
produire malheureusement
donc il est il fait beaucoup évidemment
de alors politique en termes d'élection
mais politique disons
au sens noble du terme où il défend ses
convictions et ses idées
il avait annoncé tout ce qui se passe
malheureusement maintenant
c'est ce qu'il dit d'ailleurs que
malheureusement les événements lui ont
donné raison
j'aurais préféré avoir tort
et on regarde Maxime à F3 c'est pas mal
pour les Noirs quand même ce coup de
keybé 4 laquelle a une épine dans le
pied pour les
pour les blancs et de 44 contre une 50
40 secondes de retard voilà il nous a
fait plein de fois
il me l'a fait plein de fois
mais tourin il prend la colonne ouvertes
toujours un coup logique comment il va
s'organiser sur le pion c'est ouais le
fou recule hein c'était ça mon mon sujet
là comment on fait pour protéger spion
sans le pousser on n'a pas envie de
pousser
c'est pas c'est pas comment on fait
on revient avec la dame et Maxime il a
peur de savoir non plus
que c'est moche de jouer un coup comme
ça ça obstrue le fou
elle est les noirs sont très confort là
il faut vite tout en finesse
et maintenant comment on fait jouer fou
ça ça va être un
problème pour les blancs
oui critiquer beaucoup Poutine et
critique toujours autant donc il avait
annoncé les dangers les dangers de ce
personnage
les dangers qui pouvait provoquer il
avait tout à fait tout à fait bien vu
voilà pour synthétiser
même si cette menace 2 cavaliers a fait
un bien vu maintenant ça donne la case
au cavalier
F6
est-ce qu'il va le faire tout de suite
ou en suite une minute de moins pour
Maxime c'est un peu inquiétant tout ça
c'est un peu inquiétant
faut que je bois
pour une moins inquiet
et de jouer et oui c'est logique de
mettre la tour par là comment on fait là
pour se créer du contre-jour pas évident
pas évident à jouer cette position va
nous falloir encore des tours de magie
de Maxime ah ça y est c'est 4 je vous ai
pas le proposer
ça me sort le même pion prend des trois
ensemble mieux pour les noirs
clairement c'est pas extraordinaire tout
ça
et oui et puis on prend de la paire de
fou ah faut 5 pas vu ou là par contre
comment on récupère ce pion on va faire
comme ça
tant pis on va essayer de tenir bon mais
il y a le pion à deux aussi qui traîne
c'est ça qui m'inquiète plus oh là là
une minute de plus pour égaliser
que ça va être dur tour des deux il
protège champion évidemment mais c'est
une gaffe apparemment pourquoi c'est une
gaffe je n'en sais rien
ça va ça va tourner 8 et maintenant tour
E3 va falloir assiéger ce pion
pour le récupérer il est trop dangereux
en appuyant de moins et on peut pas le
reprendre tout de suite à cause du pion
à MG3 alors ça
ça annonce des trucs sur casse noire
tout droit tour prend et la menace
mais attention à des coups comme ça qui
peuvent clouer qui peuvent être très
dangereux fou F5
non il y aura tout des 5
donc tout va bien pour les Noirs c'est
assez stable si on met le fond en 6
c'est archi stable on est complètement
gagnant
voilà Maxime c'est la c'est la cata
c'est la cata
qui va faire tourner 5 je crois
mon retour c'est 5 c'est la même chose
c'est la même idée d'être en plus précis
ça va être dur faut mettre la machine à
harnais avec en place tout recettes ok
on attaque ici une tour en 7e sacré
toujours des bons scénarios
la tour
il y a pas trop ça là
c'est jouer
c'est jouer il a vu quoi il
est-ce qu'il a vu est-ce qu'il a un coup
de bol il y a un coup de bol sur ton
profil et on reprend un
et sur quoi la même
la même parce que là non ah oui la tour
est en prise oh la poisse 2 ouais obligé
il va être il va essayer de sauver cette
fille de tout qui est pas facile
ah que c'est dur pour Maxime au moins
nul Maxime
ça sera au plus une nul normalement
il va la sauver on l'espère en tout cas
mais elle est difficile allez tout au 5
il y a du couloir un peu de partout
Dame des six à Tours 8 déjà on voit
comment ça avoir des petites peaux de
banane
on menace de menacer avec les Blancs
c'est le plus important d'un F6 c'est ce
qu'on peut pas prendre et jouer tous nos
trois on va récupérer ce pion on va
perdre celui-là mais ça devrait aller
cette finale de tour devrait aller
largement
en espérant au moins nul il va encaisser
ici et il va jouer à 4 enfin des deux
d'abord tu reprends on est en Tour
Eiffel ah oui mais la tour en
et maintenant il va se s'attaquer à ses
pions oui c'est bien joué ça tour à 7 va
être joué très certainement
la tour placée de façon idéale qui tape
sur F7 et qui tape sur assis à 4
maintenant peut-être ouais à 4 jouets
puis on prend puis on prend et
maintenant on va ramener le roi par là
et le roi noir ne pourra pas bouger j'ai
4 d'abord ouais c'est bien joué ça
et Roger trois maintenant évidemment
ranger 3 évidemment qu'il faut ramener
le roi c'est bien joué
tour des trois rois H4 et on attaque au
roi G2 c'est pareil ça va faire nul ça
va faire nul on s'en sort on s'en sort
mais que c'était dur
que c'était dur voilà c'est pas fini
bref 3 j'ai créé victoire peut-être un
peu trop tôt enfin j'ai crié nul
peut-être un peu trop tôt F5 on va
prendre nos rois G2 ça c'est toujours
âgé de et Tours C6 roi F3 moi G3 c'est
la même est-ce qu'il va prendre la nuit
les reggae
c'est pas impossible il essaye mais il
essaierait en fait c'est ça le problème
qu'on a technique parfaite de Maxime ça
ne suffira pas
à ranger 5 il donne le pion et il va
essayer de s'infiltrer avec son roi roi
G2 va être joué
et qui a tout reprend
il croyait gagner un pion j'ai 6 va
arriver évidemment que j'essa va arriver
on va encaisser tous les pions les
droits ça va être nul
ouais fin échec donc il va jouer quoi
il va jouer peut-être tout reprendre
tout reprend ouais ça va faire nul
facilement
et F5 on encaisse un F5 et c'est limité
ici qui doit faire attention 5
propositions nulles et nul signé on va
voir tout de suite s'il y a pas d'autres
parties en cours dans tout est terminé
on va découvrir les résultats le
prochain adversaire de Maxime sera Harry
Krishna mais pour l'instant on va
découvrir les résultats nuls entre
Maxime machin et grave et Eric easy
qu'on vient de voir gokash vidite ah bah
tu Prague
oh là là ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais gris Tchouk a battu gamer et ça
c'est pas bon du tout pour la première
place abdos à torof ah bah tu as écrit
China c'est pas bon non plus ça
alors on va voir quelque chose
et à la demande de la fin un point de
mis d'avance c'est quasi gagné pour
grichu mais on a une lutte féroce pour
le podium avec pragaff ennemi Abdou
Sator
ze il peut tous passer
de 2 à 5 c'est clairement très très
ouvert et une deuxième place serait très
belle
mais bossovetage de Maxime qui garde ses
chances intacte pour le
podium
on va tout de suite changer le score
toujours maximum vaincu un dans ce
deuxième journée s'il avait joué une
première journée comme la deuxième bon
il serait pas en train de se battre pour
le podium il serait clairement en train
de se battre pour la première place
prochaine partie dans 9 minutes
et on va regarder les appareils
de la prochaine ronde
tout de suite
contre mvl
aducateurs
qui fait une deuxième journée
et bien beaucoup plus modeste clairement
contre Google
on va voir c'est pas fini en tout cas
c'est une partie décisive pour Alexandre
très clairement on va se mettre en mode
VIP je crois pour les deux dernières on
va s'installer dans Public gentiment et
Maxime va chez Lagrave aura les Noirs
face à penthalar et Krishna qui souffre
quand même dans ce temps de Blitz il en
est
c'est pas c'est pas catastrophique
évidemment mais il souffre il est 8e
mais il a encore une source de
motivation il peut essayer de rattraper
vite
donc attention attention à Krishna
français qui revient bien là
qui revient magnifiquement bien
on va voir on va voir
beaucoup plus de publication là on voit
c'est le weekend aussi c'est le samedi
c'est ça aussi ouais les Indiens là
c'est vrai qu'au début il est pas grand
monde déjà hier c'était mieux pour les
Blitz
mais
là oui là il y a énormément de monde le
samedi
et on voit ce vrai engouement qui en
Inde en ce moment
quelques années déjà un vrai engouement
du public aussi pas simplement des bons
joueurs mais du public tandis que faut
avouer qu'en Chine
à l'époque où bah d'ailleurs les les
Chinois ont le champion du monde et la
championne du monde mais pas de jeunes
joueurs mais il y a jamais eu un vrai
engouement au niveau du public ce qui
est la grosse différence avec
la ouais ça serait beau de finir devant
Prague de finir de prendre une belle
deuxième place là
je sais pas ce qui se passe il y a des
execos j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y a
images des billes de départage
on va regarder Abdou Satan fin 9 et demi
donc six baguettes chaud qui revient à
10 et demi c'est Maxime gagne il a dit
ouais ça peut se jouer ça peut se jouer
clairement
mais faut des résultats qui aille que
dans l'autre sens clairement
déjà gagné cette partie
malgré tout a été 3 fois champion du
monde de Bliss 2006-2012 2015 à noter
que le titre le plus beau c'est 2015
certainement parce que c'était c'était à
l'époque c'était à l'air open donc c'est
à dire que tout le monde peut jouer
expérience c'était plutôt des tours à
fermer il reste deux rondes ouais
il reste de rampe pour aller chercher un
podium pour mvl
on va voir on va voir mais ça va être
passionnant à suivre évidemment
bon Magnus n'a pas annoncé sa retraite
il ne défend plus son titre de champion
du monde de parties classiques mais j'en
peux rapide et Blitz vous allez vous
allez le voir vous inquiétez pas pour
lui Champions Tour vous le voyez à
chaque fois d'ailleurs on le voit et il
gagne quand il joue il gagne Coupe du
Monde aussi il va juste croire que la
Coupe d'Europe des Clubs bientôt
il est aussi inscrit dans un open au
Qatar
donc il joue encore un petit peu moins
il joue
il joue plus sur online maintenant
il est il est Fandi online
mais il a joué cette Coupe du Monde qui
a duré 1 mois il a gagné à Baku
une sacrée perle c'était le dernier
titre qui lui manquait dans sa
dans sa brillante carrière dans sa
carrière incroyable
il joue au poker mais pour s'amuser il
l'a dit à de plusieurs reprises rien de
sérieux
même moi je joue au poker et Magnus
Carson
alors on sent qu'il a du talent comme
pour tout
mais
bon c'est pas son meilleur jeu
oh là là en critique Magnus mais non
mais non tu vois bien qu'il y a eu un tu
as pas vu le Emma Stone qui dit
il se plaint des tricheurs online non
d'abord c'était sa plainte ce n'est pas
de ça
enfin bon bref ça c'est résolu tout ça
sur vos amis maintenant
il a bien oui non bien sûr il gère bien
oh je pense qu'avant la transaction de
toute façon tout le monde était à la
moyenne
donc la vente du groupe les Magnus à
Chess.com
qui sait opérer en début d'année
Maxime Maxime est-ce qu'il est bien dans
le classement il est il est 4e execo à
demi point du deuxième
mais c'est très serré comme vous pouvez
le voir sauf pour gretchou qui a quand
même 11 points
et qui est là qui déjà à 3 minutes avant
Sacha et ben
que se passe-t-il
là on va voir qui joue table 2 on sait
pas
à table 3 on n'a pas de joueur en
arbitre qui nous cache la vue
on sait pas non plus les tout premier
installer bon je crois que c'est la
première fois de sa vie
c'est simplement la première fois de sa
vie
ouais je joue pas mal emblée
oui oui Bernard les jouets
à cause du climat effectivement c'était
pas la même période de l'année aussi
c'est bien dommage
et malheureusement cette année je crois
que le champion adopte en fait je suis
sûr même champion d'Europe par équipe
coïncide avec le tournoi à Saint-Louis
qui fait partie du grand cheese tour et
donc
Ali Reza et Maxime doivent jouer le
grand chestour c'est contractuel
notre ami Rex sinky
il se fige bien des dates du championnat
d'Europe par équipe
après ça part avec les Américains ils
nous prennent nous comme d'hab
alors il est quelle table Maxime il est
à la 3 on va se mettre confortablement
on va confortablement s'asseoir sur les
marches en méga VIP
on va se mettre là
et on va suivre ça
je sais pas je sais pas c'est avec
Guillaume je sais pas quoi faire de ma
vie
je fais 10 ans pour Magnus ça fait
beaucoup hein
ouais
ça fait beaucoup alors je sais pas ça
dépend j'en sais rien de quoi demain
sera fait et un problème de pendule ok
c'est pas grave cette remise en place
pas notre armée arbitre il a 12 minutes
et il joue Carlie F6 ouais non mais je
comprends je vais pas je veux pas
répondre à la place de Maxime sur le
climat tout ça c'est ce qu'il avait dit
donc
alors
que je joue beaucoup online des 5
fougères 7 B3 et on va jouer fou B2 B4
aussi un coup mais B3 plus modeste
et c'est 5 jouets par maxi mais petit
rock est-ce qu'on prend pas là je crois
qu'on prend
parce que sinon la structure va être en
général bonne pour les Noirs si on prend
des 4
alors
il prend ses 5 oui c'est tout à fait
normal mais réfléchi ça c'est bien pour
nous
on aime quand le joueur réfléchit comme
ça il a pas l'air mais il a jamais l'air
avec Christina damassa on va récupérer
gentiment le pion
mais c'est tout Didier des blancs on va
jouer ces quatre et on
en prêtant en tout cas qu'on a une
meilleure position
un vélo
et oui c'est vrai
à 5 il contre-attaque ici typique
ce qu'on fait tourcer un ce qu'on fait
fou d'eux est-ce qu'on fait puis on
prend des 5 je sais pas
faute de ok c'est très logique
et maintenant c'est à Maxime de jouer de
15 contre 2,5 tout va bien position
solide quand même pour les blancs il
nous faudra une victoire mais comme
d'hab
ça va il reste plein de pièces tout va
bien tout va bien ça joue à fond
parce qu'on fait 6 pour provoquer B5 je
crois pas
c'est très obligé de prendre mais c'est
vrai que ça replace la dame donc c'est
peut-être pas terrible c'est pour ça que
Maxime prend un peu de temps il a bien
raison
on prend en C4 pour faire perdre un
tempo mais bon pas si évident qu'elle
est assise mais ne menace rien cavalier
à 6 parce que
on a la tour attaqué à la fin donc je
suppose que Rock va arriver maintenant
on va sortir le fou de casse blanche
voilà exactement et maintenant menace de
prendre et sur B5 on joue ksc5
tranquillement
et c'est vrai que c'est maintenant c'est
40 secondes de retard symbolique
qu'il a eu beaucoup dans ce tournoi
comment il fait
à rétré chien c'est pas évident
peut-être dame B3 mp3l a l'air d'être un
coup tout à fait logique pour toucher à
rien MP3 et jouer
coûter très logique
et maintenant comment on fait pour faire
jouer ce cavalier à 6 c'est pas évident
alors et 30 secondes d'avance quand même
c'est pas anodin
il prend ses quatre il prend une
décision faut prendre arriver je suppose
c'est pas un blitz d'énerver on voit les
deux joueurs qui jouent
leurs coups d'une manière très lente
que ce soit sur le plan de la réflexion
ou sur le plan physique
j'ai l'impression qu'on est mal ouais on
est pas très bien on est un peu moins
bien ça c'est sûr ouh là là
et ce fou qu'est-ce qu'il fait en G4 ce
fou
il est un peu endormi là Maxime
et bon il peut se réveiller
le 5 a l'air quand même très fort
il faut 5 dam B2 aussi tu entends
et c'est ce qui vient de jouer
il a pas voulu aller dans les
complications
V4
alors comment on fait pour protéger
peut-être trois B1 tout simplement quoi
que ça se mettrait
et ça y est Christopher
complètement alors pour le coup maxime a
l'air un peu un peu plus mou que
l'habitude mais alors avec les salaires
complètement endormi
ça c'est une très très bonne nouvelle
et il fait 5 tour B2 ouais c'est un peu
acrobatique ce truc là ça a pas l'air
extraordinaire
et toi ouais petite case logique et
Caval et le 4 en vise des échanges ça et
c'est une gaffe tactique d'après la
jauge
pourquoi pourquoi je vois pas ça c'est
une mode ou il y a j'ai cave qui perd
une pièce qui prend des deux qui prend
des deux
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe va-t-il le voir
oh il a complètement zappé ce G4 40
secondes pour arrêter il a vu là en
général le truc on le voit en jouant
et après ça j'ai l'impression la vue
aussi
et le jour
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe ça perd une
pièce alors que ça se passait tellement
bien aujourd'hui
ça s'est arnaque c'est vrai que ça
s'arrête mais bon
comme ça
quelle gaffe de Maxime
incroyable
et ouais il a fait ça 35 secondes c'est
notre espoir c'est
ça reste du bled lamage 4 un truc comme
ça on envoie la dame dommage 4 jouets
et de ouais trop solide mais bon allez
on va voir on va voir
faut sortir la machine arnaque la
fameuse
un petit peu
centralise tout ça tourner deux peut
arriver aussi avec l'idée d'un B2
et demain aussi propose un échange tous
les échanges sont bons pour les blancs
là
ça c'est un axe
à la fois pour y croire
5 ok
26 secondes
qu'est-ce qu'il fait va reprendre ici
faire un chèque je crois pas qu'il va
faire échec non il reprend et maintenant
comment on fait en FF6 et puis on va
ramener ce cavalier à l'abordage et non
il l'empêche il joue très bien pour
l'instant avec Christina 19 secondes
contre 15 une pièce de plus pour
penthalar et Krishna ça devrait suffire
mais c'est ton jamais
c'est du Blitz cavalier 4 on revient et
le cavalier ouais c'est très bien ça
peut-être même tourner ici tourner un
jouet
et ton F7 il faut qu'il garde les pièces
Maxime évidemment
il y en a une de moins de pièces donc
c'est important de la garder de garder
autant que faire ce peu
et la clé des 6 ça a l'air d'être un
coup de massue en tour des 8 aussi oui
non c'est vrai qu'on est pas obligé de
tout changer attention attention
où il revient ah le bol ah le bol il
avait pas vu
ça ça a provoqué
abandon de la Krishna énormément gaffe
de Maxime Vacher Lagrave aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe
je crois que le podium s'éloigne là on
va aller voir Abdou ça parce que là ça
joue le gars du tournoi
évidemment
et on voit les deux joueurs donc qui a
les blancs contre eux quelque chose
qu'elle est noir un pion de plus pour
quelque chose
une nul suffit Alexander grichu pour
l'emporter dans ce tournoi on va voir
échec on va encaisser le pion et je
crois qu'il va même faire mieux que nul
ça peut être pas mal pour nous ça
attendez 8 j'ai 5 et nul il est content
nul tout le monde est content
nul tout le monde est content il fait
non de la tête mais nous on est content
et
qui est quasiment certain de gagner le
tournoi sauf si Prague l'emporte
est-ce que Prague a emporté a gagné donc
ça joue encore
il nous reste visite ah ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait pas vu une fun
partie teigneuse de visite là
ça faisait longtemps on va regarder ça
il se bat comme un diable à chaque fois
il est parti
non il est pardon autant pour moi et
visite ça joue footcore poser vite
menace maths ton G2 il va prendre G2 et
faire nul
ouais il prend G2 et ça fait nul il est
toujours avancé à la main
ouais non il y a rien il se passe rien
ça joue à fond tout le monde sait
tout le monde sait que ça va faire nul
parce qu'on a le droit
et
elle est de joueurs qui jouent jusqu'au
bout est-ce que ça joue jusqu'au pattes
prends le pion
et hydro
effectivement dommage
et gretchup donc il fait nuit avec abdos
à finale
première défaite mais au plus mauvais
moment
dommage
et Prague qui bat Google
là c'est la le désastre et oui vous
voyez j'avais peur de voir ça
on est à Grez de chouk à 11,5
et visite à huit question à huit aussi
donc faut faire attention de ne pas se
faire attraper maintenant
alors sur un petit miracle il peut
rattraper Abdou Sator c'est possible
déjà mathématiquement on va regarder les
appareils pour voir
c'est dommage
bon la bonne nouvelle c'est que YouTube
de toute façon ça je vais pas gagner le
gagne du tournoi
mvl joue contre Raja bof
et va essayer de battre Prague Google
visite Abdou Sator off et on
griden donc une nul suffit à quelque
chose pour terminer ce tournoi Prague
devra absolument l'importer mais eaglesi
va jouer à bloc parce qu'il a simplement
un demi point de moins
et Abdou ça torof il joue qui déjà j'ai
déjà oublié
il joue vite ok donc on est pour on est
pour Vidy si Maxime gagne
on est pour Abdou ça torov
non si Maxime perd on est pour visite on
est pour ados à tort
soyons pour visiter
alors il joue qui Maxime il jouerajabov
ok ok on va aller voir ça tout de suite
ah je le poids c'est à chaque fois je me
mets dans le
oula on va aller voir les parties
Maxime va chez agrafe Raja bof ou alors
on suit peut-être une autre partie
ouais nulle solide
sinon c'est
non on va rester sur Maxime et on y
rajouter un coup d'œil évidemment sur
les règles ici
Prague quand ça sera terminé
si annules par exemple rapide
qui garantit la cinquième place mais
il peut la jouer quand même Maxime il y
a pas un gros risque au pire
si il perd il est 5/6 donc tout va bien
on va voir on va voir ce qui décide
c'est dans 7 minutes la prochaine cette
dernière onde du tata style India on
aura des nouement a priori
quand même très très bien parti un point
d'avance le destin entre ses mains très
solide tout au long du tournoi très très
bon
et c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu donner la
qualité dans l'autre partie au lieu de
la pièce mais bon c'était
un choix cornélien parce que c'est une
grosse qualité avec des colonnes
ouvertes donc
ça allait pas
un petit coup de fatigue là sur la fin
ah oui dernier toujours
il y a plutôt intérêt à gagner mais
surtout il a plutôt intérêt que ça
s'arrête
il y a plutôt intérêt à ce que le
tournoi s'arrête à Jabo il en peut plus
je vous le garantis 5 sur 16 5 sur 17 il
est pas du tout habitué à ce genre de
score
donc on va voir
on va suivre ce dernier blitz de la
journée et ce dernier Blitz tout court
de ce statistique India chasse India
de Calcutta
ou Maxime de toute façon ça sera une
expérience positive vu sa performance
dans le Rapid donc il y a pas de souci
là-dessus
on sait pas si un timbreak ou pas je
crois pas honnêtement j'ai vu nulle part
on peut regarder
excusez-moi
je sais pas casser les oreilles
je crois format
ouais
j'ai pas inventé
ouais faut qu'il joue parce que il peut
plus podium si il peut podium execo
tout à fait
ils sont trois mais c'est sur place
c'est le stream officiel ils sont trois
il a légende Vichy à Nantes
Robert S
et Tanya Sanche
mais c'est incroyable de voir la légende
Vichy en commentaire
je sais pas j'ai pas écouté bon après il
est
pas plus marrant quoi Vichy au
commentaire mais bon
les gens n'absoluent du jeu
donc on peut apprendre des trucs aussi
clairement
on apprend des trucs je suppose
allez plus de 3 minutes avant la
dernière partie
il fait chaud
vous soyez en France
je crois je crois qu'il fait chaud
partout là
ouais il y a aucun risque de jouer à
fond il va jouer
il va jouer non mais je commande plus
d'escalier ça la poisse
j'ai bossé avec cramique pour le match
contre justement en 2008 on a perdu
ensuite aussi il fait chaud évidemment
salut amicale à la Francophonie qui nous
regarde je suis sûr
je suis sûr que la francophonie nous
regarde
et Maxime qui est là
un peu dégoûté certainement
de ça
des fêtes parce qu'il avait fait un beau
une belle deuxième journée la défaite
vient un peu tout gâcher malheureusement
même en Bretagne il fait chaud non ça on
le croit pas non ça c'est pas possible
qu'est-ce qu'il va nous faire mal
je voulais qu'il joue au Cap depuis le
début et malheureusement ça c'est ça
s'est mal goupillé contre la gazy bon la
partie d'avant et dommage qu'on
travaille avec cette gaffe
c'est pas vrai que je joue jamais les
tétées
c'est assez rare je joue moins 2 sur 2
mais j'en joue quelques-uns quand même
et puis
c'est quand même le plus mauvais quand
on regarde
[Musique]
alors effectivement c'est marrant il y a
plein de bons joueurs mais alors si on
regarde des prix franchement on gagne
jamais appris dans ces trucs
j'ai fait un bruit une fois mais il y a
très longtemps il y a cinq ou six ans
prochain tournoi pour mvl je crois que
ce sera la Coupe d'Europe des Clubs à la
fin de ce mois
et ensuite tu auras le grand tournoi à
l'île de Man et un peu de grande chaise
tours je suppose allez allez Maxime
ah Maxime 9 sur 17 vous voyez je suis
mauvais perdant moi aussi j'ai pas voulu
changer
j'ai pas changé de score
on change plus quand il gagne
ouais
je crois nul pas beaucoup d'intérêt
exactement il y a deux pascalificatifs
pour lui demander une française
je vais par Maxime qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire on va voir l'indication s'y prend
des 5 c'est foutu pour nos spectacle
ça c'est bon ça
il va faire quoi
où est-ce qu'il va essayer de punir
que c'est le coup normal cavalier F6 OK
Fuji 5 ou 5 de toute façon c'est les
bonnes versions de la française tout ça
fout des trois aussi
et c'est 5 jouets par tes morts à jabov
qui est un joueur de français historique
attention il a déjà joué ça a déjà fait
nul
ritchouk a fait nul contre il en voulait
plus
donc il est vainqueur de ce grand
tournoi ça c'est certain
quand on doit faire
Alexander grishou qu'on regardera le
classement à la fin de cette partie
et à Christina je sais pas ce qu'il
assure là bien sûr rien du tout en
faisant nul mais bon
tu vas avoir marre
et un pion isolé mais tout à fait
raisonnable pour les Noirs pas une
ouverture ratée évidemment c'est un peu
bizarre que ce pion insiste mais
pourquoi pas il est utile maintenant on
peut faire que c'est 6 x 7
donc rien de désastreux pour tes mots
ouais je trouve pas ça très
très 12 ouais 12 points de la part de
réfléchis là bon il fait ce qu'il veut
après tout mais bon pourquoi ne pas
jouer en plus un compatriote Prague qui
pouvait le rattraper
pas très très cool
mais bon
non il avait gagné pas quoi qu'il arrive
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai si il
perdait que Prague gagné il y avait une
égalité peut-être qui gagnait
donc oui bizarre de la part de la
ider il aurait pu aider son son
compatriote pour le coup puis pour le
spectacle c'est quand même un peu
dommage il y a du public et tout ça
c'est comme vous
voilà ça
c'est pas franchement
c'est on peut survivre de jouer un bises
de plus de plus pardon
bizarre ce que je vous dise
aucune victoire
alors il a sacrifié un pion Raja BOV
mais il a la paire de fou et un peu
d'activité là et un clouage aussi
ça valait le coup j'ai l'impression
ça va aller le coup
comment on fait
comment on fait les blancs maximum
réfléchis à aller dans le dur sur cette
dans les mains ou là
la tête dans les mains
ouais maxime a fait la même dans le
tournoi mais Raja bof assuré un truc
c'est un rapide c'est un blitz bon
franchement
au Maxime faut jouer là une minute
faster
ça fait pas plaisir de jouer ce coup
c'est à contrecœur clairement
clairement ça protège c'était pas
vraiment attaquer hein parce qu'il y a
toujours ce thématique fois 7 mais bon
tôt ou tard ça allait l'être et donc il
a décidé de prévenir
oui non max c'est quelque chose
du tournoi bon bah il joue voilà pas
plus compliqué que ça
je sais pas de pas la jouer c'est
tellement bizarre
qui est champion
et
maintenant on va voir
c'est à peu près équilibré évidemment
une huile de moi là pour un Maxime
cavalier 5 tours c'est un ok il savait
bien sorti quand même Maxime en rendant
spion c'était une bonne opération une
bonne solution
ouais tu es là tu joues sinon pourquoi
tu viens ouais surtout quand il y a pas
un résultat ça m'est arrivé de faire des
nuls en rapides en dernièrement mais
c'est parce qu'il y avait un résultat
à confirmer je dirais là
8 ou 8 et demi ou 9 bon c'est en son
pays il y a quand même des gros moyens
qui sont mis sur ce tournoi
et je trouve qu'il
c'est dommage
c'est dommage je trouve pas ça très bien
voir mal mais bon une fois de plus une
fois de plus j'ai envie de dire blame
the rules not the players
pourquoi ils font pas une interdiction
proposée nulle et comme ça c'est réglé
ça joue à fond c'est dommage
c'est vraiment dommage
c'est tellement simple en plus en rapide
et Blitz personne n'y voit que du feu
personne ne dit rien
parce que ça joue normalement
globalement on a vu il y a pas une nulle
rapide on n'a pas ce problème de nul en
rapides sauf sur les dernières rondes
donc faut faire cette règle que pour les
dernières rondes
et à ce moment là ça jouerait
c'est dommage je sais pas pourquoi ils
le font pas dans tous les tournois c'est
un truc qui me dépasse
ment
H3 pour empêcher des éventuels Kiji G4
pour pouvoir bouger de fou
François Pitt qui dit l'anglais
légendaire à Laurent l'anglais
légendaire de Laurent
le français légendaire aussi
alors
dame c'est deux
propositions
parce que c'est vrai que
ça joue solide quoique là je critique un
petit peu c'est pas très fair-play ne ma
part parce que en rapide il a quand même
fait beaucoup de spectacles avec
beaucoup de parties de décisives
bonjour bisou bienvenue est-ce que je
commande seul le tournoi non il y a
quelqu'un qui se
qui se cache
j'ai commencé seul tout le tournoi
avec notre ami du BTP aussi qui était là
quand même tout le temps
il y a
au moment le plus palpitant on est on
est sur la fin
mais je sais un professionnel comme toi
viens voir comment c'était monté si
c'est tenu de belles façons par textes
et ce qui est incroyable
c'est qu'il y a pas eu le moindre bugs
ça c'est incroyable non franchement
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
ouais à part le non il y a toujours un
truc en fait oui non mais c'est vrai le
voisin BTP il a fait du bruit
effectivement
allez ça échange tout et on va aller
voir ok ça c'est nul fini
pour Maxime qui assure la cinquième
place pour une partie c'était pas là
c'était pas la plus excitante on va voir
irgaliser contre Prague pour cette
deuxième place ça joue quand même c'est
important
la deuxième place du tournoi dans un
classement final
et on regarde et à gazic entre Prague et
Aziz doit absolument l'emporter c'est de
la c'était jouer en Coupe du monde
victoire à l'arraché de Prague mais
c'était passé un nombre de trucs
incroyable
ouais une ouverture plus fun de la part
de ML non là là on va pas il a joué au 4
c'était une Française bon
non et je connais moi il va pas répéter
je vous le dis il va jouer n'importe
quel coup droit mais il va pas répéter
ah si
ah bon ça c'est bizarre
donc on a les résultats finaux on va
regarder
gamer
et très bien revenu à nous ça en fait je
crois qu'il prend un deuxième place nul
de chouk tube de Maxime
et donc le classement final c'est gris
chouk 12 fois ce partage la deuxième
place du podium
Abdou Sator qui est revenu c'était
incroyable et Prague accroche un podium
s'il perdez la dernière c'est que
c'était la cata terminé 4e
Eric et quatrième disséminin ouais c'est
très serré Maxime 9 et demi qui paye
très cher son début de tournoi raté 0
sur 3
et 0 sur 3 donc il le paye il le paye
cher évidemment à la fin de points et
demi de retard sur le premier comme quoi
un autre début aurait pu donner des
conséquences différentes mais c'est
comme ça il est quand même bien revenu
mais malheureusement
il a il a chuté dans la dernière ronde
contre eux penthala harrishna mais bravo
à lui quand même pour
son
tournoi de partir rapide il nous a donné
beaucoup de plaisir il a été impérial
cette sur9 il nous a fait vibrer dans
cette deuxième journée de Blitz il fait
une cinquième place moyenne voilà on va
pas on va pas se mentir dans le Blitz
mais globalement un tournoi extrêmement
positif pour ma part j'ai été ravi de
commenter les parties de Maxime quasi
exclusivement parce qu'on suivait
évidemment
notre Maxime nationale qui était en
grande forme et merci infiniment de
m'avoir suivi pendant ces cinq jours et
je l'espère à très bientôt
je vous souhaite un excellent et très
chaud weekend ciao ciao tout le monde
vous les streamer des échecs comme vos
créateurs préférés tels que dis stream
Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
cheese.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre saviez-vous que vous pouvez
pimenter vos parties en ligne et vous an